Дякую.
Так, доєднуємося по трошки. Ага, в нас вже одинадцять, клас. Ще хвилиночку чекаємо і будемо починати.
Як настрій? Настя, як настрій? Аня, Тетяна, як настрій на сьогоднішній день навчальний?
Задушить плюшового мішку. Настрій. Такой.
В об'ятьях нежності.
Очень інтересна інтерпретация.
І по якому поводу така інтерпретация?
Знаєте, як це...
Є активне приглашення внешнєго мира в хаос.
А ти туди вже ой, як не хочеш, ти там вже стільки разів був.
І ти вже знаєш, як там не комфортно.
І тому ти спротивляєшся ногами і руками в дверному проємі.
Ну, так-то так.
Інтересно. Приглашення в хаос, в екзистенціальний хаос.
Ух ты! Лера Резник, здравствуйте!
У нас сегодня є маленькі студенти.
Да, ми будем вдвоєм.
Слухайте, так приємно на самом деле, рада вас видіти.
Так приємно, що за час курсу у нас тут і рождення нової життя,
і не просто трансформація ментальна, а і такі змінення колосальні.
Все, ми успіли пройти, знаєте, у нас тільки свадьб не було,
або були, можливо, я чого-то не знаю.
Кого-то замуж выйти, выдати, женить, знаєте, і все, прям все проїсходить.
Така маленькая життя здесь проїзошла.
Правда? Клас! Супер!
Олена, здравствуйте! Юля, здравствуйте! Анна, Маша, Оля, Кристина, добро пожаловать! Включайте камеру, буду рада вас видеть сегодня.
І у нас с вами 10 модуль, 10-й, 10-й, ми з вами 10 місяців, представляєте, почти год вместе. Нічого себе! Я удивляюсь, наскільки быстро время пролетело. Скажите, як вам це время? Всем привіт, привіт,
Марія.
Як вам це време? Давайте порефлексуємо одну минуту. Як вам цей час? Як він швидко сплинув? Плина час чи спливає час? Як це швидко? Все швидко змінюється? Трансформаційно? Так. І дітки в нас тут народ
жуються.
час тече Час тече да і ми в ньому лавері привіт привіт привіт дуже трансформаційно це все
проходить в нас дійсно і вже завершення вже 10 модуль а скажіть будь ласка ви як як ви з цим
Ви ще не втомилися від навчання, від масової інформації?
Від цей перед канікулами, як в школі було, дуже багато енергії, тому що скоро відпочивати.
Для чого втомлюватися, коли попереду канікули?
Ви мені поясні?
Куди вже ви бежите, Юрій? Знову вже на лижах? Куди?
Я просто гуляю, зараз пейдуть вдома і буду з вами повним на хокусі.
Добре, добре, доходьте. Да, Аліночка, як вам цей час?
Всім привіт.
Ви знаєте, я насправді, з приводу, чи втомилась, я втомилась.
У мене ще НЛП паралельно, ми взяли доповнення дехто з нас.
Ось, і я, направду, я дуже втомилась. Але, але про цьому, ну, це до того, що найближчим часом нових навчань не буде.
Ну, це не точно. Вот. Що стосується, як швидко, дуже швидко. Дуже швидко, тому що я навіть свої колезі казала,
я от тільки буквально вчора наважувалась, да, іти мені в це навчання, чи не йти, купувати, не купувати.
І зараз, просто оглядаючись назад, трансформація просто шалена. Крім того об'єму знань, який ми тут взяли, і ще доберем, бо особисто в мене, не знаю як в кого, ще є багато таких моментів, куди я не
заглиблювалась, але я це буду робити поступово уже по закінченню.
Бо не хочеться розпилятися, хочеться все взяти якісно, прям от глибоко. І сумно, Лана, чесно, сумно. Сумно того, що в нас тут вже така, ну, блін, у нас вже сім'я, ми вже всі тут, всі одне одного знає
мо, всі любимо, всі, да, це прям, ну, це так тепло, да, ми там, хтось там створив якісь свої осередки, такі трішечки вже тісніші, да, але все одно оцей вайп, оцей, ну, в нас всі дуже щирі,
дуже відкриті, дуже позитивні, в нас якихось таких, ну, по типу криз, нехай так назвам, немає.
Ти заходиш в кімнату, і особисто в мене ніколи немає обмеження, я можу відкриватись, розкриватись на всі 100,
з будь-з ким, з цієї групи, і це я говорю абсолютно щиро, і всі це точно підтвердять.
Тому, правда, я дуже вдячна, правда, всім, хто причетний до цього навчання,
І вам, Лана, за коучинг. Для мене коучинг – це такий сухий, структурний. З вами він такий дівчачий, він такий теплий, такий окутуючий. І я, як спеціаліст, точно у вас багато чого взяла. І впевнена,
що моїм клієнтам буде так само кайфово, як мені з вами. Дякую велике.
Боже, дякую, такі неємувірно чудові слова, дякую, дякую, класна рефлексія така, дякую.
Да, Лірочка, да, бачу Настю.
А я хочу прям особисто подяковать Лану.
Лана, вам огромное спасибо за ваш чудо-компас.
Мне он очень-очень-очень зашел.
Це було прям вкусьно, це було класно, це було прям неимовірно, прям вау.
Я прям так включилась, мені так прям понравилось, це було вообще щось дуже, дуже щось нове.
І от в то час, коли воно має бути, прям так допомогло, так потрібно було, це прям ма.
Це відділо, не касаємо обучення.
А касаємо обучення, ну, це новий опит, це було дуже класно.
Дякую, Лєра.
Особисто вам дякую теж дуже сильно.
Як на початку моя українська також така була.
І вона така є. Дякую.
Від серця до серця. Дякую величезно.
Дякую величезне, клас, супер, ви просто неймовірні, я бачу цю манюню у вас на ручках і бачу, як ви заходили в ці групи, коли ось так і все, і вже було важко сидіти і лежати, і вже і так, і так, но
тем не мене, ви видержали це обучення з огромним достоїством, не просто видержали, ви пройшли цей чудесний путь, і за цей чудесний путь у нас родился маленький каучонок, клас, супер.
Ми тепер всі дуже причастні, як ко-родітери, со-родітери, не знаю, як ще можна сказати.
Прекрасно, коли ви впитували ці замечательні знання.
Кстати, є таке научне исследовання, я зі своїми научними исследованнями, конечно, не знаю, за ці 10 модулів,
Наверно, вони вже устали вже, ці всі научні исследовання.
Но, тем не менее, коучинг в позитивному родительстві гласит о том,
що в кожному періоді, коли у нас відбувається рождення,
коли ми рожаємо дітей, в кожному періоді
у нас закладується определенний спектр мислі, емоцій, чувства
і всього-всього-всього, що ми изучаємо,
якого направління, де, як ми проводимо смысл в своїй голові,
як ми мисли свої настраємо.
і тому я дуже рада, що ми всі були причастни також, я просто вижу в цьому більшу силу,
к тому, що ви в цей период носили реб'єночка під сердцем, це дійсно дуже важливо.
Спасибо вам дуже за те, що розділили з нами, скажімо так, вашу, можливо, можна сказати таку, інтимність.
Благодарю, благодарю вас. Настя, ви хотіли сказати щось?
Щось, щось хотіла.
Тоже двоєкне впечатление, коли понимаєш, і грустно, і радостно одновременно.
З однієї дуже радостно, що, блядь, наконец-то.
Я ж не була в університетах, студентом не була.
Для мене це теж все нове.
Ну, знаєте, є таке всьому своє время.
І як-то таким студентом становиться, пусть на 5 лет, а на год,
ну, тож таке своєго рода, іспитання було.
І тут, наконец-то, да.
А с другой стороны, блин, грустно, грустно.
Вроде как втянули столь ка, вроде как что-то,
что-то, какое-то осознание какое-то пришло.
Вроде как бы вот сейчас как раз бы и вот в самый-самый разгар учиться втягивать.
А ты, а уже все закончилось.
Думаю, все равно пересматривать я буду еще,
если будет такая возможность, и с другой уже позиции, да,
с более уверенной, более, как выпускнику пересматривать обучение.
Я думаю, там буде відкриватися ще одна глибина.
Також всі, всі, всі, всі, всі.
Був запрос идти в життя, на річний запрос, идти своїх искати.
І це дуже прикольно, що тут як-то все стали своїми,
все стали такими родними, все стали такими вже.
Тежело.
Просто собратися, ну все взрослі, все заняті, у всіх лична життя,
все, ну, то є дуже реалізовані, заняті люди.
І ось так, щоб собратися, ну, тяжело, да? А коли у тебе коуч 17.00, ну, коучинг, все, і розписання, і гугл-календар присылають, то все, вже собрались.
Знаєте, клас, дякую, Настя. Я вам хочу сказати таку річ, дуже важливу для мене.
Можливо, в нас є онлайн-випускний, в нас буде велика конференція, але я буду дуже рада зустрітися в якійсь країні десь на якісь такі зустрічі неформальні, де ми зможемо всі об'єднатися, зустрітися і
виділити трошки часу для того, щоб побачитись,
Бо ми провели стільки часу разом і багато чого тут вивчили.
Тому якщо десь якась пропозиція, ми будемо це обговорювати внегласно.
Не тут, звісно, не зараз на уроці, але буду дуже-дуже рада.
Я думаю, що це можна створити.
В нас є такі умови і думаю, що це якісь два дні або якийсь день це можна буде налагодити.
Так? Згодні? Звісно.
Дякую велике вам за те, що ви тут.
Що можу сказати? Хочу приступити сьогодні до нашої безпосередньо лекції.
Ось у нас в кінці буде класна рефлексія, також фідбеки і сьогодні перший день, завтра буде другий день і завтра вже, але до сліз не доводитиму, не будемо доводити.
Ось, тому сьогодні розпочинаємо з таким настроєм, останній такий ривок, але це не останній, він в мене тут, в коучингу є, в 10 модулі, далі вам ще предстоїть трошки повивчати.
Ось сьогодні ідемо трошки повторювати, що в нас було, і впізнавати таку глибину сьогоднішньої лекції,
яка приведе нас до основної думки.
Бачите, всіх екран, презентацію.
Добре, сьогодні в нас такий день інтеграційний,
день інтеграції, інтеграція ментор-коуча,
професійна зрілість в межі професії,
чи не сказала, профорієнтації та довгострокова практика.
Сьогодні будемо розпочинати наш завершальний модуль усієї програми протягом попередніх модулів.
Я рекомендую вам продивитися, десь підняти свої записи, можливо щось десь вам буде неясно.
Будь ласка, наголошую, не шукайте поки що, якщо щось не ясно, не шукайте якісь інші істочники для того, щоб щось зрозуміти
Перевірте матеріали, які у вас вже є, тому що в цих матеріалах дуже багато глибини
Я розумію, що вона на початку, на початковому етапі була не така зрозуміла, але ясність приходить з часом та з практикою.
Розумієте?
І потім вже будете спиратися на референси.
Чому? Прошу звертатися до тих матеріалів, які ви вивчаєте тут в MCMM, які ви вивчаєте в мене також.
Тому що референси, які я даю, VPN вмикайте, старайтеся знайти ці ссылочки, артикули на ці посилання, які я вам давала, перекладати, використовуйте транслейт.
Тому що що? Тому що коли ви берете десь другу інформацію в інтернеті, вона може заплутувати і дуже сильно може заплутувати.
Тому, як то кажуть, стрейт-у-вей, тримайтеся, тримайтеся напрямку, не розпиляйтеся. Спочатку вивчіть, переглядайте все, що вам тут дається, все, що я зібрала, все, що є в посиланнях, а потім вже шука
єте другого, як говорять, другое мніння.
І так, поїхали. Протягом попередніх модулів, що ми з вами тут вивчали?
Ми вивчали також, ми вивчали self-discovery, це просто золото.
Золото і це така, я не знаю, такий, як сказати, бріллянтик наших всіх десяти модулів.
Не помню, на українському відео, бріллянтик, знакоме слово, но круть.
Діамантик, так, діамант такий.
Також ми маємо дуже багато прикладів запитань, ми познайомилися дійсно з масштабом всіх компетенцій, з присутністю, з автономією клієнта, з професійною ролью коуча, знаємо, що таке переноси і контр
переноси.
Трошки пройдемося. В шостому модулі вперше вийшли в системне професійне мислення, коли я давала вам коуч ООСЮІД, міжнародні стандарти, когнітивні викривлення коуча, які бувають, професійну опору та
чисте поле. Що це таке? Чистий ліст бумаги. Пам'ятаєте, коли я вам казала, що ми починаємо завжди з чистого листа?
ми маємо бути, як чистились.
В сьомому модулі ми почали працювати за складністю клієнтських станів,
ми їх проговорювали, і амбівалентність, і фрустрація, і конфлікти,
і в тому екзистенційно також, і паттерне мислення ми проговорювали,
все це в нас було.
В восьмому модулі ми досліджували також професійну автономію.
В Укатабані ми досліджували, що це таке, як це,
Чому це з армії пройшло до нас ці поняття?
Ми вивчали витримувати невизначеність у клієнтів, як вона формується, ця невизначеність,
та професійну зрілість коуча також.
В дев'ятому модулі, нагадаю трошки, ми говорили про проявленість,
Ми говорили про складні кейси, про ідентичність, про витримувати процес без поспіху до рішення.
Кожного разу кажу і наголошую, витримуємо без поспіху, завжди це просто, како чи наш, треба знати.
Сьогодні вже завершаємо цей цикл і вже інтегруємо всі знання, які ми зібрали.
Реальність професії, професійну зрілість, довгострокову практику, межі коучингу та здатність залишатися собою всередині професії.
І сьогодні я акцентую вашу увагу на те, що насправді відбувається з коучем після завершення навчання та виходу у практику.
Я знаю, що в нашій професії, в психологічній, в принципі, в допомагаючій професії, любі колеги, ми ніколи не зупиняємося навчатися.
Це буде і буде, і ще ми будемо впізнавати щось новеньке, десь брати, добирати, докупляти якісь курси, якісь навчання та кваліфікації.
Я це дуже розумію, але вже паралельно практикуючи.
Ось, будемо вивчати, як допомагаючі професії впливають на особистість коуча.
А впливають, повірте мені, дуже впливають, дуже.
Коли ти розумієш, де ти, що ти, як ти, як твоє мислення, коли твоє життя становиться просто як стиль, стиль життя, життя в стилі коуч.
Я неодноразово також про це говорила.
Сьогодні також під нім будемо підіймати тему, що таке емоціональний лоуд, invisible, emotional labor та накопичення чужих історій.
Я розкажу, як це розшифровується, де це взагалі знаходиться, що це таке.
Як коуч поступово може втрачати контакт з собою? Так, може, дійсно, може, залишаючись функціонуючим фахівцем, що зовні ти функціонуєш, а внутрішньо в тебе все, там немає ні контакту, ні опори, нічого
нема.
Чому професійна зрілість включає визнання меж коучингу?
Як формується власна професійна філософія коуча?
В нас є також філософія, у коучів, у ментор-коучів, у екзекютів-коучів.
У всіх є своя філософія, у кожної з вас є філософія, у кожного з вас.
І на що насправді спирається зрілий ментор-коуч у довгостроковій практиці?
Бо дуже важливо розуміти свої цінності.
Коли ми кажемо цінності, у нас зразу так смикається око.
Цінності? Які цінності? У кого які цінності? Давай стикатися з цим.
Ось, починаємо блок перший з реальної професії коуча, що відбувається після навчання.
Цікаво, що відбувається після навчання.
Але я знаю, що багато хто з вас тут після навчання вже має навчання за плечима.
Знаю також, якщо не помиляюсь, Крістіна, так?
Чиємо на Кристина?
Христина вже проходила коучинг, да, Христина?
Да, проходила.
Вот, ви вже проходили коучинг.
Я помню, що ви говорили о коучинге, як ви його проходили,
де це було, яка у вас була там задача,
і наскільки ви на сьогоднішній день чуваєте здесь вже інформацію.
Як вам з цим?
Тому що дуже багато в нас є спеціалістів, хто вже має хороший бікграунд, хто має з чим сравнити.
Яку параллель? Десятий модуль.
Да, вас де-то не було, ви, можливо, відсували, були свої причини на то.
Але я знаю, що ви проходите, я знаю, що ви здесь, знаю, що ви в будь-якому в присутній з нами.
Як вам эта параллель? Ви її чувствуете, не чувствуете?
Як вона вам отзывається после 10 модулей обучення з десь со мною в коучингі?
Чувствується дуже.
Я вже говорила, я проходила до цього у Михаила Саїдова обучення.
І там дуже хороше, мощне обучення, круті знання.
Але коли я столкнулася з коучингом в первый раз, у мене було отраження, отрицання.
У мене було, як це ко мене приходить, чоловік платить мені гроші.
А я просто молча посидела, послушала, позадавала вопросы,
не помогла, не посоветовала, не спасла.
І получается вот этот накопительний эффект,
і потім ще подача от самих преподавателей.
У тебе все починається в голові,
і ти починаєш ще вовремя практики понимати цю силу,
коли ти не мешаєш клієнту своїми, а я думаю, так, а треба так, а зробити так,
то людина буде просто теряться, а ти, а людина розкрыває свою силу.
І вот поэтому на цьому обученні я поняла, какая-то сила активного слушання пространства,
відсутті якогось аналіз, правильно, неправильно, не будь судьй, не будь учителем.
Я считаю, що один із наймніших інструментів в допомагаючих практиках.
Ну і психотерапія професіональна.
Отточити навыки максимально для того, щоб бути безопасним человеком для другого человека,
Безопасним спеціалістом для другого чоловіка. Тобто максимально відтачити ці навики, так?
Так, так, так.
Дякую большое. Юрій Товган, скажіть мені, будь ласка, хочу почути вашу думку. Я знаю, що ви також маєте дуже класний бекграунд.
Мій бекграунд — це виключно життя. У мене не було бекграунду на навчання.
Я сюди прийшов, тому що коли я дізнався про коучинг, то Юля стала топом на ринку, я подумав, це цікаво подивитися, який підхід буде правильним.
Наскільки я правильно роблю чи неправильно, ефективно чи не ефективно.
І я кайфанув загалом від цього.
Тобто до сьогодні для мене сам показник, що я дійшов до кінця, тому що я дуже багато навчань проходив, дуже багато інфобізмів, чого робили.
сам показник зробити щось настільки цікавим, щоб люди доходили до кінця, і тут показник дотримання до кінця
людей дуже високий, що показує саму якість того середовища, яке тут створюється, от, того тут кайфово.
Дякую кожному, хто до цього причетний, хто є частинкою цього вкладу в це середовище, це класно.
Дякую. Дякую, Юрій. Дійсно, ви визначили такий бізнес-показник, що ми доходимо до кінця, і це дійсно класно.
бо інформація топ, інформація корисна, і з цією інформацією вона цікава,
і ви знаєте, куди ви можете йти, бо тут дійсно зібралися дуже різноманітні і програми,
і люди, спеціалісти, що визиває такі емоції, а що там буде далі?
А що там буде далі? Цікаво буде дойти до кінця, що там ще нам дадуть.
Класні, кайфові люди, скласно, з багатьома, я познайомився, поспілкувався ближче, з кимось ближче законектився, з кимось щось цікаве можна створитися, з кимось вже якісь є певні результати, тут в ць
ому плані кайф, I like it.
Клас, дякую, дякую велике. Окей, поїхали далі. Дякую, Юрій, дякую, Кристина.
І так, що ж у нас відбувається? Ключова ідея така цього блоку, що більшість програм навчають коуча, як проводити сесію, як ставити запитання, як будувати практику.
Але дуже рідко нам говорять про іншу сторону, як саме допомагаюча діяльність наша може впливати на нашу психіку та на внутрішню структуру спеціаліста, бо дуже може впливати. І робота коуча – це пост
ійний контакт із, в першу чергу, невизначеністю, людською невизначеністю.
По кожного разу до вас приходить людина, ви не можете знати нічого там, ніяк там, абсолютно. Тобто ви просто ось це новий проєкт, новий проєкт, новий проєкт, так? І ми стикаємося з болем та внутрішні
ми конфліктами кожного разу, раз за разом. Ми стикаємося з очікуванням і кризами, а ми стикаємося з емоційним напруженням інших людей, так?
І коли ми кажемо про те, що працювати з людьми, ми розуміємо, просто взяти, наприклад, маємо якусь бесіду, і десь в цій бесіде, допустим, просто незнайомі люди,
і хтось каже, я теж коуч, я теж психолог, бо я працюю на касі з людьми, і ось через мене проходить 150 людей, і я теж психолог, я теж всіх слухаю, і все тому подібне.
або там майстер манікюру також каже, а я теж психолог, я теж всіх слухаю,
бо мені тут приходять час, годину, півтори, дві, теж щось розказую, і так далі, і так далі, і так далі.
Але, але, скажіть мені, будь ласка, от просто, наприклад, як ви можете сказати,
як ви можете сказати, от просто рандомно, хтось з вас, підійміть руки,
як ви можете сказати, коли нам кажуть, допустим, от ви стикаєтесь в таку ситуацію,
Я кажу, я теж психолог, ти знаєш, скільки я людей прослухаю за той час, коли я нігті пилюю, або, не знаю, або з чоловічої сторони інтернет прокладаю,
там кожного разу до людей в будинки приходжу, до нових і так далі, і так далі, і так далі.
Що можна сказати в цих випадках, щоб не просто себе захистити, а щоб знати, як реагувати?
Як ви могли би реагувати на це?
Скажіть. О, Настя, велика. Аліна, добре, добре. Чи є хтось, хто може ще щось сказати?
Дякую. Давайте, Настя, Аліна, давайте.
Аліна, так, давайте.
Якщо можна, я скажу, бо того, що я, власне, прийшла, наважилася вчитись конкретно отримати диплом психолога,
вникнути в професію, будучи спеціалістом з лазерної епіляції.
Тобто, я прям, і в мене реально було от таке чітке відчуття, що я просто, я точно психолог уже,
Без диплому, бо того, що я чую. Але зараз я розумію, що це було по типу менторства. Я ділилася власним досвідом. І це людям допомагало. Ясно, що моя емпатія, якісь мої особисті переваги допомагали д
івчатам.
і я це ставила в копілочку
психолог, я психолог
але зараз реально смішно
реально смішно, бо того, що
коли ти вникаєш
коли ти йдеш прям
в ці чіткі, структурні
тут є грані
які не можна
переступати
ясно, що
також це залежить від людини
в принципі
але
я точно
та хто пилила ногти казала та я настоящий психолог я всіх слухаю ти знаєш скільки я людей
слухаю кожного дня ти собі ти собі навіть нового уявляєш у тебе там три-чотири в мене десять
клієнтів і я вже приходжу з такою головою бо я не слухалася всіх проблем і тра-та-та і пішла
поїхала, так? Да, Лана, це от я можу це підтвердити, так все і відбувається.
А коли ви здобуваєте досвід вже навчальний, такі, оп, як той мемчик, да, того, хто там був, ти актер такий.
Ну, да, добре, дякую, клас, дякую, Алін. Кристина, да.
Якщо мене щось таке скажуть, я скажу, вау, здорово, який ти молодец.
Я це доказувати не буду, тому що це безполезне.
І є таке, що якщо потрібно доказувати, то 100% треба сказати.
Якщо людина скажет, я розкажу, то якщо так, вау, яка ти крута, і все, без проблем.
Клас, супер, клас, спасибо.
Настя?
Я б сказала, що слухати і слухати – це різні різні різні.
Сказали б, сказали б. Так.
Слухати і слухати – різні різні різні різні різні різні.
А ти думаєш, я не слухаю? Ти знаєш, скільки я слухаю? Я їх пістоянно слухаю? Ого!
Спеціаліста именно відличає то, що він слухає так, що клиент слухає сам себе.
І тому, що я научилася за ці десять місяців, я точно можу з собою забрати.
Що чужой совет і мій, найклассний совет, нахрі нікому не нужен.
І він нічого, він не інтегриється в чоловіка,
Тому що ми разні, різні цінності, різні убеждення, різні видіння, різні среди, різні...
І саме класне в цій спеціальності то, що рідом з тобою чоловік слухає себе і розуміє, що йому добре, лично йому, що у нього внутрі піднімається, що йому важливо.
це спеціальна сечка а так послушать Да да свободне уші касса свободне уші Ну в принципі всі так
посіб большое питання не просто да Юлія бачила ваш коментар так можна нічого не відповідати я
питаюсь про вашу реакцію як ви можете реагувати як могли би відреагувати випрос в тому що
Як можна реагувати, як би реагували. Добре. Дякую. Спасибо большое, Настя. Олена?
Ну, у меня почему-то сразу возник такой саркастический вопрос в том плане,
Тепе це платить за те, що ти пилиш ногти, а не за те, що ти слушаєш.
Получається, що ти совміщаєш.
Але якщо копнути губже, то чоловік, який не має цього образовання,
наскільки він буде всі ці історії пропускати через себе,
і наскільки він буде вносити це все додому і в себе не контейнювати і наскільки довго його тоді хвати.
Дійсно, так і є, бо буває людина без відповідальної, відповідної освіти наслухається,
так, дійсно, наслухається і потім каже, що вона дуже втомилася, бо емоційно там вникала енергію свою,
там, витрачала, і там, і так,
і так, і все.
Ей дуже-дуже це
було важко.
Добре, дякую. Так.
Да, бачу коментар, да.
Доплату береш? Так, сподіваюся, доплату береш.
Ага, добре. Юрий,
як би ви отреагували?
Була ли б у вас какая-то реакція
в принципі? Може, вона і не бути, просто
я інтересуюсь.
Задайте ситуацію, пожалуйста, снова, потому що я тут
немножко отвлёкся.
Ну, ми говоримо о тому, що дуже багато людей є, допустим, де-то у вас зустрічається в якому-то кругі з'явлення, з'явлення, ви говорите о себе, я психолог, я там коуч, ще ви себе презентуєте, да, і
другий чоловік вам говорит, собеседник там какой-то з вашей компаниєю, говорит теж вам ситуацію, ну, объясняє, говорит, а я теж психолог, ти знаєш, скільки я людей прослушала, или там женщина теж
говорит, а я вот там ногти цілими днями пилю і теж слушаю, допустим, ну, то есть, я теж психолог.
А що зараз? Психологи? Каждий второй психолог, все, хто роботають з людьми, все психологи, то есть, ну, вот такое вот, такая ситуа.
Была ли б у вас какая-то реакция на це? Или была ли б, или не была ли б, і какая?
Да, ну, кожен чоловік, в целом, по жизни психолог, вот, просто кто-то имейт, этим пользується, а кто-то нет.
Вот. Твої результаты по жизни показывают, какой ты хороший психолог, или какой ты хороший коуч.
Я считаю, що часть психолога, или коуча, она присуща каждому чоловіку, вот.
Це частина розуміння життя, просто хто вводить це на розумінний рівень і, як би, робить висловно свої професії.
Але так чи інакше, це частина присуще кожному чоловіку.
І наскільки ти добре їй справляєшся, показує, отображає напряму твоє внутренєє стане і те, як ти відносишся до миру.
Вопросики, що ти хочеш отримати в відповідь від мене?
Ну, це не обязательно про відповідь, це просто ваша реакція.
Тобто ви, можливо, так отреагаєте?
Можна гиперпатична. Я можу не слушати людей. Спокійно. Я можу просто спростити, а ко мне какой вопрос? Человек задаст вопрос. Если он не задаёт вопрос, зачем мне говорити ответ?
Не, тут не вопрос. Вы услышали, здесь есть некое такое, кто услышал обесценивание?
А, допустим, обесценивание на здоровье.
Окей, добре, супер.
Замечательно.
Щас объясню, чому я вас спросила.
Всех.
Спасибо большое.
Це кажуть, коли кажуть, ой, моя мама...
Мені як психолог, погані новини.
Тобі мамі підрювати психолог.
Да, да, да.
У мене була історія, клієнт, якби психолога.
Говорить, ти хочеш на супервізію?
Она говорит, нет, зачем я супервізію тратиться на подружки?
Позвоню, все расскажу. Прекрасно,
вообще, замечательно.
Замечательно.
Я побачила знецінення, тому я її написала, бо це однозначно, що тут такого, що ти там мучишся, я тут теж можу просто, що кого хочеш прокоучити, але це зовсім різні речі, але цим людям немає сенсу щ
ось пояснювати,
Бо зрозуміло, якщо людина вже так відповідає, це вже як ізнесінення, якась неповага, проблема з кордонами трошки.
Навіть якщо вона так думає, не дуже гарно це озвучувати.
Так, Юрій, є що відповідати?
Я озвучу, чого моє питання вас трошки в стопор воно завело, я це переосмислюю.
У мене просто є правило в комунікації, що сенс комунікації в отриманні реакції.
Тобто я відштовхувати цю комунікацію буде від того, яку реакцію я хочу отримати.
Ви мені дали якби це в розплох, і мене в розплох застали.
Тому я вам дав якісь свої бачення, але там буде залежати від того, яку я реакцію хочу отримати.
Якщо я хочу її спровокувати, я зроблю все, щоб її спровокувати.
Захочу заспокоїти, я зроблю все, щоб її заспокоїти.
Захочу, щоб вона мені заплатила грошей, я зроблю все, щоб вона мені заплатила грошей.
Питання просто моєї цілі в цій розмові. Питання того, хто буде поруч.
Це якось буде зачіпати мене як людину чи не буде зачіпати мене як людина?
Я захочу показати, якщо з боку буде моя сестра, і захочу показати їй, як можна людям піздюляй давати гарно і м'яко.
Дуже багато факторів, які впливають на комунікацію.
Все залежить від того, де ви будете знаходитись, в якому становищі, в якому обществі, і хто і так як повинен слухати і слухати, і де ви повинні відстояти свої границі, відповість, або не відповість,
або можете просто промовчати.
Якщо я йду по вулиці, там бомжі з боку деруться, як би, ну пусть всі деруться, якщо вони ко мене щось хочуть, мені про що уйти відтуди, ні, влізати в драку, як би, не всі драки стоїть увагу, не всі і
сторії повинні бути начати.
Клас, супер, окей, окей. Чи є хтось ще зі своєю думкою хтось що може сказати?
утрималась утрималась як в депутатській отрималась скільки отрималась проголосувала стільки отримала
стільки добре дякую насправді дуже цікаво і мені було цікаво вас послухати вашу думку
Чому? Зараз поясню. Дивіться, Emotional Law та Invisible Emotional Labor активно досліджуються в психології допомагаючих професій вже багато років, особливо в сфері психотерапії, коучингу, медицини
та соціальної роботи.
І у нас є така американська дослідниця Кристина Маслаш, у нас є Маслаш, можна сказати, Маслаш, хто як, вимовляє, буде референси всі є в кінці, ось, значить, що в нас, так, зараз я хочу весь екран так
ставити на весь екран, слайд.
Не можу щось зі мною, сьогодні не хочу працювати, але потім, може, спрацюю.
Значить, в своїх робітах Христіна про професійне вигорання описувала,
що головне виснаження спеціаліста виникає не лише від кількості роботи,
і ми це можемо також знати, а від постійного емоційного включення
у переживання емоцій інших людей, і емоцій, і життя інших людей.
Так? Так.
Коуч, що він робить постійно? Постійно, на автоматі, отримує увагу, регулює свій власний стан,
залишається присутним, витримує напругу, стримує бажання врятувати клієнта.
Це на автоматі все проїсходить. Контейнює складні переживання.
І велика частина цієї роботи залишається невидимою ззовні.
Саме тому це називається invisible emotional labor, то є невидима емоційна праця.
Вона є також дуже схожа, десь її прострілювали таку паралель з материнством.
Ось, коли є невидима емоційна праця, треба вистроїти контакт, треба вистроїти всю сім'ю, емоції, стан в сім'ї, атмосферу, погоду.
Ось також там наблюдається така історія. Далі Даніель Сігель у роботах з Interpersonal Neurobiology також поясняє, що нервова система людини реагує на емоційний стан іншого навіть тоді, коли ми цього
свідомо не помічаємо.
Ви за собою таке помічали, що ви реагуєте на емоційний стан іншої людини? Помічаєте. Звісно, так. Дійсно, так і є. Тому після звичайної сесії коуч також може помічати, що в нього є втома, в нього є
спустошення, є бажання ізолюватися, є внутрішнє перевантаження.
Все це є, може бути, тому що що? Тому що на автоматі ми свідомо не помічаємо, як ми підключаємося до інших людей
І це зовсім не означає про слабкість людини, нічого це про слабкість не каже, це просто означає, що професія передбачає постійне емоціональне залучення
Це те, що я вам казала раніше про життя в стилі коуч, те, що ви постійно включаєтесь, ви не просто постійно включаєтесь, ви включний, просто включна людина.
Є поняття функціонуючий коуч. Одна з найнебезпечніших професійних пастук – це стан, який умовно може називати функціонуючим коучем.
Коли коуч в стані продовжує працювати, продовжує проводити сесії, звучить завжди професійно, використовує правильні інструменти, але, що він робить, поступово втрачає контакт з собою, тому що він на
протязі багато-багато часу ось в такому ритмі.
Так, і повернемося тут до думки Карла Роджерса. У концепції конгруенс він писав про важливість внутрішньої цілісності спеціаліста. І ми повертаємося з вами, я рекомендую повернутися до селф-дискавері
. Знову, Карл Роджерс наголошував, що клієнт відчуває не лише техніку, а й справжню присутність людини.
Ось, тобто ми про це також говорили. Коли коуч починає виконувати роль, коли коуч починає бути лише функцією, приховувати власне виснеження, приховувати свій стан, приховувати тому, що він не доспав,
не доїв, не до щось, втрачає емоційний контакт з собою, тоді професія поступово стає механічною.
Ця людина, вона холодна, вона просто набір інструментів і технік.
Ось, зовні такий коуч може виглядати стабільним, він робить свою роботу, все ок,
а всередині вже з'являється таке, знаєте, відчудження, автоматизм,
втрата сенсів та відчуття внутрішньої порожнечі.
От, Єлом в своїй книзі «Gift of Therapy», також книгу я дала референс,
Описував, що справжня терапевтична присутність неможлива без живого людського контакту самого фахівця з собою.
Контакта, коли немає з собою, нічого в цьому житті не відбувається.
Видно, що людина, вона така, знаєте, як нацянута, як струна.
Вона постійно там, ти на неї поглянеш і вона тако, знаєте, повернеться і вже тобі там, я не знаю, матрицю всю щитає просто.
Все, все, розказала, все. Тому що вона в постійній готовності. І таких людей можна побачити. Ваше завдання, будь ласка, на завтра ось таке легке завдання. Я ще нікому не давала, але дам зараз.
Моніторимо соціальні сітку сьогодні
І знаходимо людину, яку ви побачите отакою, як струна
Хто це може для вас бути?
Знайдіть цих людей і скажіть завтра
Я вас спитаю, почнемо з цього, скільки людей ви знайдете таких?
Експертів, я не кажу зараз про
Я кажу з експертів, допомагаючи професій
Добре, як вам завдання? Промоніторити, зібрати. Знаєте, коли ви в соціальних сітях, ми збираємо цей аватар клієнта, або аватар конкурієнтов, або щось, щось, десь експертів збираємо.
Ось, точно так же, зберіть мені такий аватар на завтра, добре?
Окей.
Далі, таких людей видно, видно абсолютно.
Ось, ризик втратити себе у професійній ролі.
А, ще, дивіться, зберіть такий аватар і проаналізуйте,
де коли ця людина випадала.
Тому що, коли ми аналізуємо, там може бути перерва в таких сітках, може бути перерва.
Перерва там, коли людина там десь була-була-була, потім пропала, потім знову була, потім знову пропала.
Бачите, публікації десь були в липні, потім десь в грудні публікації пішли і щось, і щось.
І на це обов'язково зверніть увагу, який був стан у людини в липні, коли була остання, наприклад, публікація,
яка була публікація в грудні, коли вона пішла. Добре, проаналізуйте просто цей стан.
Юрій, я бачила, ви там десь розмовляєте, я потім ще раз повторю. Добре, ви бачили, трошки відволікаєтесь.
Дякую, я почув, що ви щось на завтра підготувати, я такий, що зібрати завтра.
Ага, та я почув, я почув, я чую, як ви чуєте.
Добре, добре, добре, я, це я.
Ви навчаєтесь, ви навчаєтесь, добре?
Потім, є великий ризик втратити себе в професійній ролі.
Допомагаючі професії часто створюють прихований тиск, я маю бути стабільним.
Через це коуч, звісно, поступово забороняє собі в тому, соромиться власної вразливості, відчуває провину за емоції
та починає боятися виглядати недостатньо професійним.
Любі колеги, я вас готую для роботи, для реальної роботи.
Я не хочу, щоб ви зараз, розумієте, вийшовши з навчання,
знаєте, ось в рожевих окулярах, пішли просто собі там,
опа, ще, все буде, знаєте.
Має місце все, що в нас тут є.
І ми маємо розуміти, чому, заради чого, як ми йдемо в цю професію.
Добре? Ось.
Далі, хочу також взяти за приклад Дональда Шона.
У концепції з рефлексів практичною він писав, що зрілий спеціаліст – це не той, хто не помиляється,
ми можемо всі помилятися, а той, хто здатний усвідомлювати власний внутрішній процес.
Це губиться по дорозі, будьте уважні.
Усвідомлювати власний внутрішній процес, порой це буває таке, що це може загубитися по дорозі.
І якщо коуч в першу чергу перестає помічати свою втому, власний страх, внутрішнє перевантаження, потреби у підтримці,
він починає втрачати контакти з собою як живою людиною.
І в довгостроковій перспективі до чого це призводить?
до професійної десоціації, емоційного аніміння, вигоряння, цинізму або прихованого професійного вигоряння.
Професійного одиночества коуча.
Про що це?
В першу чергу, це на відміну від багатьох професій, цей коуч часто працює один,
немає стабільної системи підтримки,
залишається сам на сам із великою кількістю людських історій.
Який це коуч? Без чого він?
От просто голосом пам-пам-пам скажіть, без чого цей коуч?
Без супервізії, без супервізії, без супервізії, без супервізії, без личної терапії.
Вот просто волк-одиночка, она вот пошёл на профессиональну смерть, скажем так.
Оленка Сидык, ви плачете чищо?
А, ви смієтесь?
Пошёл вот это на смерть, а я така, о госпож.
Бедоложный.
Ідущий на смерть приветствует вас.
О, Василю, ти з нами, клас, приємного.
Світлана Батуріна, десь я вас теж побачила, ви зникли.
А, ви теж їсте.
Приємного, все, доєднуйтесь, доїсте і доєднуйтесь, чекаємо на вас, приємного вам.
Звітаю, дякую.
Enjoy your meal, enjoy your meal.
Добре, поїхали далі.
Да, дійсно, такі люди, є таке професіональне одиночество коуча, но коуч може зайти в одиночну роботу, но при этом все-таки необхідно виходити і вигружати весь свій контейнер.
Пітер Хавкінс в роботі супервізіо-коучів наголошував, що ізоляція є одним із факторів професійного виснаження.
Коуч може починати залежати від успіхів клієнтів, сприймати відсутність результату як власну невдачу, сумніватися у своїй цінності, шукати постійного підтвердження своєї професійності.
Саме тому професійна зрілість включає супервізію, рефлексію, професійне середовище, виходимо на конференції, на менторство, десь-десь виходимо і налаштовуємо цю здатність чесно визнати власній людсь
кий досвід.
І наразі багато таких груп є, я знаю, створено підтримуючі групи. Підтримуючі, де в мене є також, я підписана на деяких таких діячів, де створили свою таку, назвали професійна будка.
Ось всі туди в будку ідуть і там собі жаліються, знаєте, там собі виховують в собі силу, здатність проявляти свою силу.
І в висновці в нас є таке, що професійна зрілість коуча – це не здатність не втомлюватися, і не роль людини, яка завжди стабільна.
Розумієте, зрілість – це в першу чергу здатність залишатися живою людиною, помічати власний свій стан, не втрачати контакт з собою. Якщо відчуваєте, що вам щось не вистачає, йдемо в люди, просто в
иходимо в люди. Не перетворюємо професію свою на функцію. І будуємо практику, в якій є місце не лише для клієнта, а й для самого коуча.
Ось тут в мене є, Василю Байчу, зараз повернусь до тебе, в мене є тут осередок, такий класний, осередок, так це називається, не знаю, середовище, середовище, де люди збираються, знаєте, і я також вед
у професійні, трансформаційні ігри.
І в мене тут запросили, а я кажу, а я також веду, а в мене також є кешфло, в мене також є гра на самоцінність, а я також можу вести мафію і так далі.
А мені так підходить людинка така класна і каже, а сама ти хочеш пограти? Я така хопс, звісно хочу. Вона така каже, так приходь пограй, а потім будемо грати там, ну далі, будемо розвивати там свої іг
ри і так далі.
Я вам хочу сказати, це дійсно тут не з таким розмахом, як це відбувається в Україні, як це в нас там пафосно, красиво, там знаєте, все це ресторани, в нас такі класні є кафешечки, простори, де нетвор
кінги, де люди збираються.
Тут в нас на озбережжі, знаєте, це як ось затока, там, знаєте, десь Кароліна Бугас, ось в Одеській області, знаєте, і от на пісочку там розложилися, і все прекрасно, знаєте, настрій неймовірний, ней
мовірний, і просто з картками, просто з хустками на очах, але вже наша команда розрослася до майже 20 людей, 20 вже стоять в очереді просто, щоб пограти.
Тому що зібралися такі люди живі.
І в мене питають, що там на кишфлоу, будемо збиратися?
Я кажу, ти знаєш, ні, я хочу ще пограти.
Я хочу ще пограти, я не хочу, я все, не хочу.
Чому? Тому що коли в нас є потреба така значимості,
ми можемо зрозуміти, де цю значимості брати, наскільки її брати.
А де є потреба бути живою людиною серед своїх просто,
де тебе розуміє, де ти можеш внести свій якийсь там досвід або щось,
Неважливо, ти там також можеш себе побавити, також можеш себе, знаєте, з'єднати з осередком, з суспільством і так далі, і так далі, і так далі.
Ось, тому це дуже важливо розуміти, коли ми можемо там десь трошки, ага, щось мені там з моїм контактом, там щось не так, ідемо в люди, виходимо, просто виходимо.
Коли ви виходите, вас побачать.
Коли ви сидите в чотирьох стінах, ніхто не побачить.
І хоч ви там умнічаєте, скільки хочете.
З 20 дипломами ніхто не побачить.
Добре. Юлічка, да.
Лан, а як з вашого досвіду?
Оці виходи в світ, просто десь пограти, зустрітися з іншими людьми.
Які вони ще мають вплив?
на людину на вас як на спеціаліста або на вас як на людину тут важна людина як на людину
в першу чергу ви соціалізуєтесь якраз про контакт з собою ви соціалізуєтесь ви розумієте де
ваше місце в соціуму в обществі кдє ви находитесь ось в цьому в цій атмосфері де ви є чи не
Заблукали ви десь вдома, десь в своїх думках, не зарефлексували дуже часто, не зайшли в глибокий самоаналіз.
Бо, доки ми там собі щось міркуємо, соціум вже там абсульдає Машу Глашу Васю, понимається?
Доки ми там вдома щось собі о глибокому, допустим, міркуємо щось таке, понимається?
Ну, це щас условно, допустим, обществу там обсуждає крипту, а ви вдома думаєте о глибині какой-то другої.
І коли ви виходите, ви понимаєте, о, подожди, я там себе що-то накрутила, о, чекай, я зараз собі там щось намислила, не знаю, що. А тут, насамперед, тут все легко. Це перше. Тобто ви з'єднуєте з ре
альністю.
Так, тому що ви бачите, як можна більше людей, що там відбувається. Потім ви розумієте, наскільки ви релевантні до цієї реальності. І потім ви можете там і свої відповіді якісь знайти, а куди рухат
ись далі.
І хтось десь щось сказав, а ви вже коучи, ви маєте рівень слухання, ого-го, розумієте?
Ви не просто там поверхностно десь почули, ви вже все собі відчули і почули, що вам там треба, розумієте?
І коли ви там, ага, а мені треба це, це, це, і ви там просто вкинули, а що думаєте там?
І от така релевантність, як вимірювати свою релевантність?
Коли ви даєте якийсь інформацію, якийсь, знаєте, вливаєте, я кажу, вброс інформації, ви щось дали, якесь направлення, напрямок, і ви такі, оп, ага, так, це не зайшло, а що зайшло, а зайшло ось це, а
га, що сказали про цю, а скільки людей още про це думає, і так далі, і так далі.
Тобто, ви себе релевуєте з соціумом.
Де ви є, де є соціум.
І як, наскільки вам рухатись далі.
Це дуже добре.
Мала, що знаєте, зшого?
Типу, ну, ми ж майже все це саме робимо в онлайні.
І тут, мабуть, цікаво самовідмінність від того, коли ми це все ж робимо в онлайні.
Тобто, ми ж там теж спілкуємося, теж там робимо якийсь вкід своєї,
якихось думок, да, і дивимося, хто з цим погоджується,
хто реагує, не реагує, про що там спілкуються,
тобто це ж теж, в принципі, схоже, але це різне.
І от різниця впливу.
Мені це, просто чесно, це як особисте дуже актуально.
У нас ця тема зайшла, бо останні роки я розумію,
що в мене низька така активність, офлайнова, дуже.
І от зараз мені цікаво, як це повпливати могло на мене.
Ну і це зараз багато хто з цим стикається, особливо в еміграції.
Атрофія, є таке поняття, атрофія.
Коли атрофується поняття вашої вербаліки, не вербаліки.
Виходити в онлайн – це таке розслаблене позиція.
Коли ви виходите офлайн, вам потрібно більш дій.
Коли ви більше дієте, ваш мозок більше дає якісь накиду варіантів.
Коли ваш мозок накидує більш варіантів, ви демонструєте активність.
Тобто активуються ваші нейронні зв'язки.
Це на уровні хімії, в будь-якому, фізики, хімії, нейронів в вашому мозку.
І коли ви вже виходите, ви розумієте, як ви скануєте людину, людина може вам сподобатись.
Я чому пропоную вам зустрітися? Я реально пропоную вам зустрітися, я дуже хочу з вами зустрітися, не повірте.
Люба точка міри, а де можна? Тільки не Україна, к сожалению. Ось.
Розручили, розручили і сказала ні.
Ні, ну дивіться, в Україні, я в Одесі буду в вересні, мене запросили на свадьбу, на весілля, ось, тому буду в вересні в Україні 20 числа, з 20-го, 21-го по 24-25-е буду в Україні в Одесі.
Ось, тому хто може в Одесу, welcome. Чому? Тобто коли ми виходимо в соціум ще, як ми себе поводимо, як ми сидимо, хто є наш фаворит, ми оцінюємо візуально габарити, ємність, ємкість, візуал працює на
наші нейрони зовсім інакше, ніж тут онлайн.
Розумієте? Ось я вас бачу просто десь посюди, у мене там камера увеличиває, десь ви бачите мене, може десь по плечі.
Ви не бачите людину, коли ви в офлайні, ви бачите людину в повний зріст.
Ви розумієте, як вона себе поводить, які в неї повадки.
Ви щитуєте інші, ваш мозок щитує інший емоційний стан для вас.
І тоді ми можемо взяти більше інформації, тому зараз онлайн дуже обмежує, це по-перше.
По-друге, якщо навіть є спільнота в групах Телеграм, я завжди навіть зі своїми працівниками,
навіть з людьми, з якими я працюю, я виходжу на відео, я не розумію, що таке спілкуватися по телефону вже давно, я виходжу, я стараюся виходити на відео, я не можу, просто не можу, я хочу бачити люд
ину, я хочу бачити людину перед собою, і коли мені кажуть, я не причесена, то мені все равно, яка ти, я не дзвоню тобі, щоб побачити твою прическу,
Ілі що там в тебе, то там сонна, чи там вмита, чи не вмита.
Я тебе ніяк не можу тут просканувати.
Я хочу бачити людину.
Ось.
І тому завжди кажу, спілкуйтеся.
Ось так, зглазу на глаз, ви можете абсолютно спокоєно себе проявляти.
Так?
Юля, зрозуміла, як це може на вас вплинути?
плакатильна кімната да плакатильна кімната теж є
Добре Василю що хочете сказати в мене два питання як починаючому коучу
який ще можна сказати не так а ще багато заробляє для прикладу дозволити собі супервізії
і ну от оце оця ситуація тому що я розумію що колись я точно
собі думав ну блін ну не зараз не цей типу особиста терапія окей але от супервізи це перше
питання а друге рекомендації поради чи т.д. і т.п. от для прикладу в мене була сесія з 16.30 до 17.30
ну я до тої сесії прийшов не в ресурсі я там мав сьогодні фотосесію взагалі останніх два тижні
такі в жопу зайняті скажімо так і як ставитися до такого раз і друге типу як діяти коли ти не
я не в ресурсі не провести сесію але я не в ресурсі бути на всі 100% те як я можу дати так
я в ресурсі там на 60% от такі дві ситуаційні задачі Ну перше про супервізію я вам скажу по
регламенту одна супервізія полагається на 8,5 сесій такий є регламент провели 8,5 сесій вам
необхідна одна супервізія які ризики що буде якщо когось того не буде робити не в ресурсі
нема коштів чи ще щось там ще щось там ще щось ну в першу чергу не збирайте щоб були ризики в
чергу я про це вже казала ось тут проговорила дивіться уважно дивіться що що проїсходить
які ризики Пожалуйста от вам залежите від успіхів клієнтів сприймаєте відсутність
результату як власну невдачу можете сумніватися у своїй цінності шукати постійно підтвердження
своєї професії Тобто це все також відноситься до ризиків якщо немає супервізії от Пожалуйста
це Пітер Хавкінс, це про те, що я 3 секунди назад сказала, є силка, почитайте,
тобто ви просто підете, підете, підете по цьому стану, ресурс, потрош, це не одразу,
це може бути рік, може півроку, може бути два роки, але ви будете просто коучем на автомації,
Розумієте? Ось.
Тобто буде також ризики професійної десоціації, емоційного оніміння, цинізму або прихованого вигоряння.
І потрошку ресурс падати, падати, падати.
Також десь можете не відзначати свою втому, десь буде внутрішнє перезавантаження.
Контакт з собою втрачається. Ось, це найголовніший ризик.
Це про супервізії. Тому супервізії – це дуже така важлива частина.
Якщо ви працюєте в складних випадках, то також треба розуміти складність випадків.
Дивіться, це про клініку зараз я сказала, більш про клінічні стани, більш про людину, яка втрачає себе, розумієте?
Яка втрачає себе не просто там, як мені знайти свою самоцінність, а більш про такі складні діагнози, розумієте?
Тобто не діагнози, може бути і клінічні діагнози, може до вас людина вже йде там вистанавлюватися, я не знаю, яких клієнтів ви можете брати, берете чи не берете таких клієнтів. Це більше стосується
того, що вас торкає, коли вас торкає, і ви розумієте, що вас от прям всерденько прям там вже, блін, там і хочеться і допомогти цій людині, і там і щось, і так, і так, і так, і так, обійняти ще щось,
це про переноси, контрпереноси ми кажемо,
ми там переглядаємо переноси, контрпереноси.
І якщо вам не вдається забувати,
не просто забувати, а залишати на папері цього клієнта,
і ви про нього постійно думаєте, ви носите його в супервізію.
Розумієте?
Своя терапія – це своя терапія.
А про супервізію – це більше ось така ситуація.
друге питання було не питання що там про друге питання про втому ну тобто наскільки коли ти
розумієш коли я розумію що я на сто відсотків 60 відсотків я можна швидкий коментар що що
швидкий коментар да можна не можеш дати забери якщо у тебе два питання то в мене три відповіді
Амінь все продовжуйте клас ну не знаю ядине я не в'їхав я б не забирала не все має сенс що має мати сенс
а все що має сенс не має сенс Юра спинисямо мій мозок і пить так розслабтись трохи не можеш дати
забери все ну це до першого питань чи до другого у тебе було тільки що я не можу дати на 100% можна
дати на 60 то не можеш дати не можеш людині щось дати то забери те що в неї є їй буде легше
все одно не давай забирай людина приходить щоб тобі щось віддати ти не можеш її щось віддати
назад то забери побільше в неї вона тобі більше велиї душі створи цей простір якщо так якщо
ділитись то фактично десь ну тобто я з собою стаю тоді трошки незадоволений умовно говорячи
але потім я це легалізував під час сесії сказав клієнці тобто що так я частково ну типу я після
фотосесії два тижні в принципі вони мене бачать що в мене зараз твориться ажіотаж і і тоді мені
полегшило тобто коли я вийшов вправді можливо якби я з цього взагалі почав то було би ще менше
питань до себе але я розумію також у клієнтка теж потребує цієї сесії бо є такі які можна
перенести а є такі які ні ось і тому мені в принципі десь захотілося це винести як як питання
ну тобто де ця межа та тобто що ну я в принципі розумію де ця межа в мене але чогось десь мені
хотілося це легалізувати на всю спільноту якось так ну дивіться бувають випадки дійсно різні і дійсно
є клієнти яких можна перенести яких не можна перенести але в першу чергу якщо ви розумієте
що ви не ресурсний я б зробила в першу чергу я б зробила повідомлення що заздалегідь що не
не пояснювати що в мене там фотосесія або в мене щось так так так я якщо б мені так написав мій коуч я
просто до цього коуча більше не пішла б ну дійсно мене взагалі не не має хвилювати що там в нього сталося але коли
Як би мій друг сказав, трошки не культурно буде, «міняти їбать не должно».
Ось, озвучу неозвучене.
Вам стало легче, Юрій?
Так, дякую.
Ну, ви не можете таке озвучити, я вирішив озвучити неозвучене.
Нехай всі зрозуміють сенс і глибину цієї думки.
Добре, дякую велике.
Дякую, Юрій.
Коли ви пояснюєте своє ментальний стан,
тобто, що у вас зараз так, так, так,
я можу перенести, можу вийти,
якщо щось там, все залежить від ситуації,
якщо щось у вас таке, що треба там обсудити,
ви знаєте кейс клієнта, ви знаєте, що там сталося,
тобто, дати, зрозуміти клієнтові на початку
можна навіть з повідомлення.
Ось, і це буде теж правильно.
Тобто немає, моя відповідь,
немає такої определеної
якої-то границі, для того, щоб
ви якось орієнтувалися.
Ви відчуваєте
свого клієнта самостійно.
Де є клієнт, що є, як є,
і що ви там можете дати, як можете дати.
Розумієте?
Добре.
В принципі, я відповідь отримав.
І тут навіть питання, для чого
оправдовуватися фотосесією, пішло поїхав.
Тобто, що я розумію, що в мене, знаю, в відповідному плані є, ну, типу, перетини і т.д. і т.п., тому я десь так сказав, але, в принципі, так, почув, висновки зробив, дякую.
Дякую. Елена Гавріловна, здравствуйте. Я вас дуже давно не виділа.
Здравствуйте. Ну, я вас вже час підслушиваю потихонечку. Я просто їхала з роботи вдома, тому я тут і я все слуху.
Супер, супер. У вас стиль змінился, наскільки я вижу, или нет, или що?
Давно вже.
Да, ви покрасивіли якось, не знаю, мінус 20 у вас наліця.
Спасибо, після трудового дня.
Ну, спасибо.
Хорошо. Окей, продовжаємо далі.
Так, почнемо наступний блок. В мене будуть ще питання.
Дивіться, в першому блокі я ще завершую.
Чому спиталася за вашу реакцію і привела приклад, треба завершити перший блок, привела приклад. Я завжди питаюся і завжди хочу почути фідбек, хто готовий, до чого готовий, як готовий. Для мене це важ
ливо, тому я, знаєте, так цікавлюся, в кого з вас є та упора, як вона проявлюється.
Навіть якщо не проявлюється, це теж результат, якщо ви там не вийшли голосом або не підняли руку, нічого не сказали, нічого, це теж результат, це теж відповідь ваша, але вона така, це теж має сенс
стосовно того, що якби ви реагували на, якщо там десь в суспільстві казали, що я теж психолог, я теж там то, я теж там всіх слушаю і так далі, і так далі, і так далі.
І отут є дуже класні паралелі, які ви самі собі даєте, хто на що як реагує, як Аліна відреагувала, як Юля відреагувала, як Юрій відреагував, Настя, хто як реагує, хто реагує просто мовчки, що тіпа ок
, Кристина як сказала теж, ну я тебе поздравляю, молодець.
Маша Хреб просто сказала, допустим, я тебе спитаю, береш доплату за це чи ні? Ось така ситуація.
Тому я дуже рада, що ви так реагуєте. Чому? Тому що це вже є відповідь, наскільки ви опорні в собі, наскільки вже маєте контакт з собою, в професії йти далі.
Бо як ви помітили, цей перший блог був про свою ідентичність, про свою таку філософію.
Іще хочу тут додати коментар Єліни, тому що Єліна Гаврилова,
ви говорили, що ви, да, работаєте масажистом, і ви теж говорили,
що, кстати, упомінули где-то в своїх речах, що я вот теж очень много людей прослушала,
Ідея в чому? Ідея в тому, як вам тепер після десяти модулей, після обучення, після того, скільки інформації ви рознаєте,
як ваша реакція тепер менеється ли, не менеється, все нормально і то, і то ок.
Як ви могли би реагувати, коли ви тож віршаєте людей і вам кажуть, що дай я теж роблюю з людьми, о, я ще той психолог,
у мене такий жизнений опит, мама дорога, не горюй, я там всіх слушаю, як би ви...
Ну, як би я сказала, є таке хороше теж вираження, що мама, у якого троє дітей, може бути врачом-педиатром, але вона не врач-педиатр.
Тобто, ну, як би так.
Але вона ім не є. Совершенно верно?
Вона може бути воспитателем.
Да, я хотіла це сказати, але мені було в транспорті, мені це було неудобно, я все слухала, але не могла говорити.
Клас, супер. Дякую велике. Так, клас.
Поїхали далі, в нас на черзі практика, але ми її пройдемо після перерви.
А зараз пійдемо до другого блоку.
І в другому блоці мені теж дуже цікаво з вами поговорити про межі коучингу та професійну зрілість.
Ось, ключова ідея цього блоку, якщо я достатньо хороший спеціаліст, я зможу допомогти кожному.
На ранніх етапах навчання у багатьох коучів формується така несвідома ідея.
що я достатньо класний спеціаліст, я дійсно можу помовити кожному.
Але в реальній практиці практика поступово стикає коуча з іншою реальностю,
що не кожен клієнт готовий до змін, і ми це знаємо,
але кожному клієнту потрібна така допомога, яку ми можемо відчувати всередині себе.
І не кожен запит може бути коучинговим, не кожна проблема вирішується через усвідомлення.
І не кожен процес має швидкі результати. Це дійсно є так. Ось це є ознака професійної зрілості, якщо ми це розуміємо. Саме тому професійна зрілість починається там, де коуч перестає, прям как оче наш
, рятувати, витягувати, доводити власну цінність, давати прям совєти, прям совєтувати, а почему ти не зробиш так, да що тебе мешає, зробив отак.
або сприймати себе як головну причину зміни іншої людини.
Далі хочу поговорити про те, де коучинг не всесильний.
У сучасній культурі, особливо зараз, прямо у сучасній культурі,
коучинг часто подається як универсальний інструмент змін.
Але зрілий коуч прекрасно розуміє, що коучинг має межі.
Які межі має коуч?
Скажіть мені, будь ласка.
Да, Кристина.
Психітрические заболівання,
з которими должен займатися врач,
і інфантильна позиція клієнта,
якщо він не хоче,
то не брати в роботу чоловіка,
який не готов на себе брати свої 50%,
щоб не була ця історія
тянем потянем выкинуть не можем так да да да спасибо большое кто добавит еще что-то
вы правы кристина что еще можно добавить нет ни экологичные запросы например давайте разобьем
стратегія на пейтсесі, як убити мужа і не все з тюрмію, не екологична. Ко мене с таким приходити,
пожалуйста. Я беру такое, я такое беру. С таким ко мне, пожалуйста. То, що не екологична, сто процентов.
клас хорошо суперпасіба Васілій тихотерапевтичні тобто травма минуле і прям і гострі гострі
стани швидше за все цієї самої травми також не коучнула парафія
хто працює з гострими станами психолог психотерапевт психолог не працює з гострими
тільки психотерапевт психотерапевт-психіатр ну психіатр само собою під гострим станом я
маю на увазі не обов'язково психіатричні а тобто людина в момент травми там для прикладу
якщо хтось тільки там помер чи ще щось там і людина горює там психолог теж не лізе
Желательно туда психологу не лезть
Психолог консультує
Психолог консультирує, ще раз, є определенний регламент
Психолог консультирує исключительно
Психотерапевт психотерапевтирує, владеє техниками, методами
Защищен в определенному методі, дає психотерапію
Психіатр лечить і направляють к психотерапевту.
Психіатр лечить, 25% дають таблетки, 75% дають психотерапію.
Гострі стани – це не психологічна тема.
Це має бути психотерапія, де є захист в методі в якомусь,
де людина дійсно знає, як працювати, використовувати техніки, особливо при втраті.
в мене тоді питання от я є лікар-невропатолог та і в вересні я можу піти на спеціалізацію
психотерапевта і в через 6 місяців я маю можливість мати вже психотерапевта і я без без методу грубо
говорячи як тоді дотор до транзакційного є там своя терапія в схема терапії кататожна до
транзакційного є але умовно говорячи я буду без метода як регламентуються ось такі психотерапевти
які є лікарі психотерапевти психотерапевти це треба я не маю права в межах цієї конференції
говорити про таку тему дякую немає компетенції ось ПТСР посттравматичний стресовий розгляд
А також психотерапія, психіатр може долучитися також, якщо прям гострий стан, 25% медикументозний, 75% психотерапія.
Також, так, ПТСР.
Ось, тому психолог, якщо ми кажемо про психолога, психологи консультують, консультанти консультують, психологи трошки більше, бо вони мають базове психологічне.
Вони консультують психотерапевти, базове, психологічне, плюс захист у методі.
Захист у методі обов'язковий.
Тоді йдемо психотерапевтувати.
Ось, обираємо собі метод, беремо собі курси, щупаємо де, що, як, тоді далі лізимо.
Не лізимо, а йдемо далі.
Поїхали далі.
Так, дійсно, ви праві.
І коучинг тут все не про коучинг.
це не про коучинг ми пам'ятаємо він про що про що як вбити тих хто в колишньому і забрати
звідом ресурс ресурс прозріст прозріст да совершенно верно дань он проресурс про рост про точку
про туда, йдемо далі, давай, усілюємо свої сильні сторони,
дивимо, де ми там, може би, що-то просіли, дали якусь слабіну,
взяли силу і пішли далі, і пішли далі, так, так, це дійсно.
Ось, знову повернуся, люблю, Пітер Хавкінс.
О, друзі, колеги, хотіла сказати, хто у Лондоні буде про травму
вересні. Я йду на конференцію,
велику конференцію, Габора Мате
і ще я
давала вам
одного автора, боже, в нього
тройнає фамілія.
І він також буде на цій конференції.
Я прям пишаюся цим.
Я прям заздалегідь
купила собі квиточок, це буде
13 вересня. Я прям буду
транслювати, взагалі, просто супер-супер.
Це ці вчені,
Ці люди, які вивчають все, що, в принципі, вам дається тут.
Вони старенькі вже, старенькі, бо вони по 20, 30, 40 років в потоці, в ресурсі, в навчаннях, в ісследуваннях.
І ось дають, на них тримається всесвіт.
Пітер Хавкінск у роботах про коучинг супервізія.
Наголошую, що професійна зрілість коучу проявляється не лише у вмінні вести процеси, а й у здатності розпізнавати, коли коучинг перестає бути достатнім.
Ось, розпізнавати теж дуже важливо, коли коучинг перестає бути достатнім.
Ми можемо ментор-коучами бути, можемо вести, але коучинг також перестає бути достатнім.
Не кожен клієнт перебуває у стані, де коучинг буде ефективним.
І ось вам приклади. Гостра травматизація, клінічна депресія, психічні розлади, тяжкий кризовий стан, психічні розлади сказала Крістіна.
Тяжкі кризові стани, хто сказав, Василя або Юлія, хто АПТСР, так, теж кризовий стан.
Глубока дезорганізація особистості, де є дісоціація, де є розлади особистості, можуть потребувати іншого формату допомоги.
Ось, також не кожен клієнт реально готовий до змін, навіть і що говорить про зміни.
От є люди амбіційні, говорять про зміни, але до змін не готові.
Я думаю, ви таких чули і бачили.
І це є люди в оточенні також, є амбіції прям сверх, але не готові.
І коли ти питаєш по смарту, що ти готовий зробити прямо зараз, а людина така, нічо, нічо.
Іноді людина хоче просто зменшити свою тривогу, іноді хоче бути просто зрозумілою,
Іноді треба її погладити, хоче підтримки, але не готовий змінювати структуру свого життя.
І це не робить ніякого клієнту поганим, ніякого.
І не робить ніякого коуча неефективним.
Запам'ятайте собі.
Межа між коучингом, терапією та наставництвом у нас є в дослідженні Едвіна Дехана.
А, Вандер Колк, Вандер Колк.
Вспомніла, Вандер Колк.
От я йду на нього з Габором Матев, він буде ім'я на Б, Вандер Колк, він також буде, давала вам з нього матеріал.
Едвін Дехан у дослідженнях в Critical Moment Syncoaching описував, що найскладніші моменти для коучу часто виникають саме тоді,
коли клієнт входить у глибокий емоційний матеріал, коли коуч починає втрачати межу ролі або виникає бажання врятувати клієнта.
Ось, тут закінчується коучінг. Тут закінчується коучінг. Все.
Ends of our professional skills.
Коучінг не лікує травму, не замінює психотерапію, не є директивним наставництвом
і не передбачає, що коуч краще знає, як має жити клієнт, куди інвестувати,
де тратити свої грошики, як розлучитися, якого мужчинчика вибрати або жіночку, так далі, так далі, так далі.
Ага, не знає цього коуч, нічого не знає, нічого.
Ось, саме тому професійна чесність іноді проявляється у здатності чесно сказати,
що, вибач, тут потрібен інший формат підтримки, в мене є колега, колега колезі, у колезі є колега і так далі, так далі.
Я бачу, що цей процес виходить за межі коучингу, бачу, що треба така-така підтримка, я можу бути з тобою далі, я можу тебе супроводжувати, але я хочу питатися тебе до того, щоб доєднати сюди людину,
яка професійно тебе стабілізує у цьому-цьому-цьому.
Чи бачиш ти в цьому сенс, чи не бачиш? Можу сказати про це тобі зараз, чи не можу? Як ти себе відчуваєш в цьому моменті? Ми не всесильні. І буває дійсно так, що клієнт в мене також було, це багато
разів, коли клієнт дійсно приходить і треба було покупатися там, де я не копаюся.
Я маю гештальт, а я не використовую гештальт, тому що в мене є мої методи, два методи зі своїми техніками, які дають мені класні результати, я туди не лізу. Але є людина, яка там, подождіться, цілес
но орієнтована терапія є і гештальт.
Є така людина, де треба було в тіло, де треба було зайти, я запропонувала, окей, три сесії, все ок, ми супроводжуємо, працюємо в трьох, все конфіденційно, ця людинка зробила свою роботу і пішла далі,
ми пішли далі.
Ось, так це працює, так це класно, працює все ок, всім ок.
Тому, Юлічка Печенка, виходимо на вулицю, тобто в люди, знайомимося і отримуємо від всесвіту прям всі блага.
Гді, хто, як працює, в якому методі, хто, в чому найкращий.
Я знаю, що ця людинка в цьому найкраща, я туди відправила свого клієнта, на ножки поставили.
Але я би не знала цю людину, якщо б я не вийшла в люди.
Я би не знала.
Я знаю її так, ось там десь онлайн,
але мені було важливо прям в люди побачити,
соприкаснуться, нонвербал відчути,
про що ця людина, побути з нею в її полі,
не просто онлайн.
І це по-іншому зовсім працює.
Так, ну що, ідемо бігом на перерву на 10 хвилинок і повертаємося, заходимо в практику,
бо маємо ще багато-багато ще обсудити, багато що обсудити.
Окей? 10 хвилинчик, визв'язуємося в 41.
Все, чекаю цьому.
Дякую за перегляд!
так хто в нас найпунктуальніший Юрій бачу вітаю вітаю знову дякую що ви з нами і так
в сьогоднішніх новинах віщаємо про практику що ж поїхали зараз хочу повернутися до практики
з першого блоку, який ми з вами закінчили тільки, що, щойно.
І поки всі доєднуються, повертаються, доєднуються, практика в нас на 30 хвиленочок, практика в нас в парах вже.
Давайте я вам трошки поясню до початку відкриття залів, поясню суть практики, що ми будемо тут робити.
Добре? Окей.
Так, бачите, да?
Практика у нас називається «Що відбувається зі мною в професії?»
Прямо поглиблюємося, поглиблюємося.
Почимаємо трошечки йти, заходити в глубину.
Анна Кохір, так, я слухач сьогодні, Любі, добре, добре.
Часовий розподіл по 15 хвилин, загальний по 30 хвилин, фідбеки в загальному залі, в нас, не в кімнаті.
Мета нашої практики – дослідити власний професійний стан і помітити, що насправді відбувається з коучем у середині професії.
Це не класична коучингова сесія. Фокус в практиці буде на внутрішньому виснаженні, якщо воно є, на страхах, на професійній самотності, на ролі ідеального або не ідеального коуча, на втрати контакту з
собою, якщо є контакт, немає контакту.
Тобто, на втрату контакту з собою. Один учасно говорить з позиції коуча, який вже працює або уявляє себе у довгостроковій практиці, тому що не всі можуть працювати ще.
Другий учасник, тобто коуч не заспокоює, не рятує, не мотивує, не намагається виправити стан ніяк.
Завдання просто через уважні питання, відчути ці питання, допомогти людині чесно дослідити свій професійний внутрішній стан.
Приклади питань скриньте собі, які можуть бути, але я хочу, щоб ви їх відчули, коли людина з вами говорить.
Тобто це практика на те, щоб ви відчували стан свого клієнта і які питання ви можете задати.
От просто розслабитися і не по шаблону йти, але шаблон нехай буде, нехай він у вас буде, для того, щоб ви розуміли, що ви можете задати, яке питання.
Я хочу, щоб в очікуваному результаті клієнт помічав свої точки виснаження, можливо усвідомлював десь емоційну ціну професії, вийшов із ролі ідеального коуча у більш живий контакт з собою, чесніше поб
ачив свій власний професійний стан.
Ось така мета цієї практики. Тобто практика ще раз, що відбувається земною в професії.
Все зрозуміло. Да, Елена?
Ну, а якщо я як коучу не работаю зараз?
Вот, поэтому я і сказала, що хто-то може працювати в позиції коуча,
но хто-то працює, а хто-то представляє себе долгосрочну практику.
Ви можете собі представляти цю довгосрочну практику, що ви начнете в довгосрочній практиці працювати.
Ще питання є? Питань немає.
Заскринили собі питання.
І поїхали, відкриваємо зали. Я тут, я з вами.
О, можна мене з Катію поставити?
Не можна. Можна як попадеться?
Можна, можна.
Кристина, попрощаться, у мене начинається шаббат. Благодарю за обучення, за знання.
Кристина, буду рада вас видіти завтра.
Уважаємо, понимаємо.
Окей.
Так, добре.
Дякую, що є тільки два слухачі.
Так, я тоді відкриваю кімнати.
Сами можете заходити.
Дякую.
зал 9 Юлічка у нас Юлія Петченко не вошла Юля спориш там одна Юлії тут немає да Юлії
Петченко споруч переміщу в інший зал да не зашла Юлія Петченко
Добре, все. Перемістила.
Дякую, Велика.
Юля?
Так, я тут.
А дивіться, в другому і в третьому залі у нас по три людини.
Можна їх по два, тому що практика не двоїх.
А там ще Анна Кугір і Карась Тетяна, вони писали, що будуть слухачами.
А, все, зрозуміло, так, добре, дякую.
Не втратимо, пацівно.
Добре, дякую.
Дякую за перегляд!
Дякую.
Добрий день.
А зорієнтуйте, будь ласка, до котрої практика буде.
Буквально ще одну хвилину.
А, супер, окей, супер.
Так, я чекаю, дякую.
Дякую за перегляд!
І так, було дуже душевно, я вам хочу сказати.
Із всіх залів, де я змогла понаблюдати,
це було дійсно дуже душевно.
Душно чи душевно?
Душевно. Дуже.
Прямо до серця.
І я вам вдячна за те, що ви так відчуваєте один одного
настільки глибоко, що знаєте, що спитати,
Де спитати, де слово вставити, де, знаєте, розкрити особистість.
Не просто, знаєте, не просто сухо спитати, а розкрити саму особистість людини як спеціаліста.
Це прям услада для моїх вух. Дякую велике.
А тепер скажіть мені, будь ласка, що вдалося, де в залах я не була?
де не встигла почути, що вдалося, як вдалося.
Ви пам'ятаєте, я вам казала, що яка мета, в першу чергу, мета цієї вправи –
це усвідомити емоційну цінність, ціну професії.
Вийти з ролі ідеального коуча в більш живий, цінний контакт з собою, почути і побачити власний професійний стан, помітити свої точки, можливі точки виснаження.
Чи були, чи є, чи будуть, чи як, де є мінуси, де плюси, де що можна підсилити. Скажіть, будь ласка, що вдалося?
Хто готовий поділитися?
Да, Настя.
Я себе поймала на тому,
що я, розмовляючи о коучингі,
о такій, як професії,
я спокійна.
У мене вже немає цього переживання,
заїкання.
Я не коуч.
Я не коуч, я тебе говорю.
Об цьому все равно продолжаю настойчиво.
Я не коуч, да.
Потому що навешала на це слово
таку сужену,
дуже формативну
історію,
і
тому спротивляюся.
Але я об цьому говорю спокійно.
Спокійно о роботі, о тому,
що, як я практикую.
Тобто мені дуже спокійно в цьому
озвучити це вже.
Окей. Настя, я знаю,
що ви вже зараз активно практикуєте.
Да.
Є ли параллель, що тоді було до активної практики, і що зараз?
І є ли що відмітити?
Є ли що відмітити?
Ну, наверное, перед входом в сесію у мене нету таких переживаний.
Я приймаю і так, і так, і так.
Ну, я понимаю, що...
Ну, захожу, действительно, чистим листом.
я не понимаю, що буде на сесії, я не готовлюсь никак.
Я поняла, що я інструменти взагалі можу нескільки гибридних зробити,
можу взагалі не включити в сесію інструменти,
ніякі, можу притянути часті інструмента куди-то,
в конкретній сиюминутний вот этот вопрос.
Да, випросами, да, да.
Ви є інструмент.
Могу переключать, ну, то есть я не готовлюсь к сессиям, я же говорю, потому что я поняла, что я так подготавливалась там к первым сессиям, так, и вот так, и вот так, и вот так, а ну, знаете, как
вообще в другом направлении поезд поехал, и у меня это не застало варафону, поэтому я приняла, ну, что я иду, и я не знаю, что будет, вот, я могу точно остановить сессию, для себя приняла, что я могу
, например, остановить сессию и сказать, это вообще не в моей компетенции, или, ну, это, ну, то есть это тоже ок.
Я зрозуміла, що може бути і так, і так.
Могут бути інсайди в сесі, а може бути і не бути інсайди в сесі.
Ти все, що хочеш, може бути так інтересно.
В моменті, пишеться все в моменті.
Класс.
Спасибо.
Спокійствие, только спокійствие.
Супер.
Лена Гаврилова.
Угу.
Подождіть, подождіть, минуточку, минуточку.
Зарядка.
А ви микрофон не включили?
Блин, я так хорошо сказала. Ну ладно, попробую повторити.
Если, ну, как я себя чувствовала, да, вот в этой практике,
то я все равно переносила это все на массаж, на тот опыт.
Потому что здесь у меня еще мало опыта.
Була я с Машей, ее тестировала, и она, конечно, супер.
Вот чувствуется, что она на своем месте, чувствуется, что уже нет страхов,
она знает, откуда подпитаться, откуда взять ресурс, сколько ей надо клиентов в день.
То есть, ну то все, она уже все знає, она уже расставила, разложила все по полочкам,
и ей легко и хорошо.
А меня все равно уносило туда, потому что опыт там большой.
А тут еще он маленький.
Как-то так.
Спасибо большое.
Как думаете, чего не хватает вам того, что есть у Маши?
чого не не хватает ну мы с машей это проговорили она тоже спрашивала чего мне не хватает и ты ж
массажи тоже не сразу стала делать и вот-вот стала экспертом и все это самое наверно мы
тем что нет вот именно учителя и нет той поддержки который ну а профессионалу у меня
дитей сумасшедшая поддержка а вот именно профессионалов вот поддержки нет учителя
нет туда наставника не знаю человек который с большим опытом вот как то так а еще чего
если так подумать еще чего ну если это про уверенность то я не могу сказать что у меня
у меня нет уверенности в этом, я могу провести сессию, я знаю. А вот я не знаю. У меня куча инструментов, а как их применить, вот пока я не знаю.
Власне, коли почали говорити, ви сказали таку вещь, що у Маші є вже чіткий план, і вона чітко знає, скільки клієнтів їй потрібно в день, скільки, в принципі, клієнтів їй потрібно, який план у її є.
Да, вона красотка.
План.
План, я поняла.
Ну, опять-таки, я не понимаю, какой он должен быть план?
Что це означає?
Всегда відталкиємся від того, що ми хочемо, чого ми хочемо достичь, в якій ціли.
І зачастую, як правило, це про що?
Про дисципліну?
Про дисципліну, про гроші, про зароби ток.
Ну, в общем, спасибо, Маш.
В общем, мені важко перейти в цю грань.
Я і тут більший спеціаліст, і тут я можу.
А от як це слепити, я не розумію.
Мені це складно, поки мій мозк це не розуміє.
Добре. Давайте спитаємо у Маші.
Дякую.
Боже! Боже!
А що питати у Маші?
А що питати?
Маша, а скажіть, будь ласка, про який план йдеться?
Про що? Від чого ви відштовкуєтесь?
Можна дати.
Від чого я відштовкуюсь?
Від практики.
Я просто спробувала ось так.
Спробувала ось так.
Мені не зайшло.
Я зрозуміла, що мені тумач стокати.
Я тоді якби не в ресурсі.
Я хочу бути максимально...
Ну, кайфувати від процесу.
Тому я зрозуміла, що мені більше трьох не окей.
Тому в мене більше трьох нема клієнтів на день.
Який план?
У мене є наставництво, я створила собі ком'юніт, де мені кайфово, в нас річний клуб, де ми підтримуємо одна-одна. Якщо в мене є якийсь завтик, я десь щось понімаю, що порефлексувала-порефлексувала,
сама не можу. Я така, вже ж професіонал, я така, ага, Машка, нормальнося і піздіш, треба цих чоловіків розбиратися. Пішла, пропрацювала, не хожу з цим, не мудрую, не зливаюся туди.
Все, рішила, ага, понятно, вот оно що, все, погнала далі, якось так.
Елена, запомнили?
Можна з цензурою?
Да, я запомнила все, я це розумію, такий же план у мене є в моїй ниші.
А вот як совмістити це, а як запустити тут параллельно нишу, вот це я не знаю.
Та ти вже його совміщаєш, ти вже береш людей, ти вже їх навчаєш, ти вже їх тренуєш,
Покажи, що ти сертифікований, офігенний ще і коуч,
і що будеш прибирати їхні строфі,
і подимай своє наставництво в масажі,
діляй чек і продавай, іди, і кайфуй.
Та не кричи на мене, я пугаюся.
Так, ти крута, ти офігенна, я не розумію,
я не розуміюся, чому ти от це сомневаєшся.
Дякую. Нет, я пошутила, ти не кричиш, я просто...
Классно, ти можна, стільки інструментів, стільки знаєм, стільки...
Давай, let's go!
от так так це працює дякую велике клас супер супер супер супер добре поїхали далі поїхали
Далі. Світлана Батуріна, Катерина Ентель. Що вдалося? Ліра, Лі, Резнік, хто готовий?
Я можу сказати.
Давайте.
Не знаю. Я якось себе досить спокійно почуваю, бо я для себе зрозуміла вже раніше.
Я точно буду працювати і мені подобається, цікавить саме класичний коучинг.
Але зараз я більше все ж таки працюю в бізнес-наставництві, бізнес-тренерстві.
Я бачу, як я там даю результати, і коли до мене приходить людина, яка хоче отримати результат,
це дає ось цей такий, ту таку емоцію, що ти на своєму місці, і ти можеш допомагати.
Це якраз про допомагаючу професію і таке інше.
Стосовно коучингу, я була з Оленою, і я для себе чітко розумію,
що мені потрібно закінчити хоча б цих два навчання, в якому зараз я є.
І що зрозуміло для себе зараз, я це, в принципі, і знала,
але Олена мені сказала, що, Сідик, якщо до мене дуже багато приходять,
наприклад, люди в бізнес-тренерстві, я бачу, що вони не готові,
Я не зможу, наприклад, з них зробити якийсь бізнес-проект.
Тому що в них є питання по самоцінності, по внутрішній опорі, по дисципліні.
І таку людину неможливо вивести на якісь результати, цифрові результати.
Їй неможливо це дати, бо вона весь час сидить ось там в цій своїй історії.
Їй треба повернути контакт з собою, їй треба повернути її опору, її цінність,
а далі вести до результату, так?
Саме так. Тому в мене є там написано два курси зараз.
Я таких жінок відправляю на ці два курси базові.
Перший курс внутрішня опора, жіноча ідентичність і другий дисципліна зрілої жінки.
Я не працюю зараз саме в коучингу, саме з самоцінністю, з внутрішньою опорою,
бо я ще не готова до того, і я усвідомлено це роблю.
Єдине, що я хочу поставити собі якийсь дедлайн, коли я почну це робити,
коли я не буду відправляти тих жінок, які проходять до мене на мою енергію,
до інших спеціалістів, а буду брати їх до себе в роботу.
Я точно знаю, що мені треба собі виставити ось цей дедлайн і план,
і згідно нього я точно знаю, що я почну це робити.
Ось. Десь ось так.
Але я себе достатньо спокійно почуваю, я розумію конкретно, що я можу давати,
А що я на сьогодні ще не можу чи не маю ще таких досвіду і знань.
Я розумію, досвід набирається з часом, з практикою, все це так.
Але ось так поки що в моїй голові просто.
А про саму вашу внутрішню опору або контакт з собою, як ви думаєте?
Ну, якщо до мене приходять зараз навіть в роботу, там, в бізнес-тренерство, бізнес-коучинг,
там, написання стратегічного плану, там, розвитку, масштабування і таке інше,
якщо я бачу, що ця людина не готова, я не працюю з нею.
Ну, типу, я не захожу, я знаходжу достатньо, ну, слів і аргументів і спокою,
щоб їй пояснити, що я не можу їй допомогти, я не зможу з нею написати їй ось цю історію,
і довести її до результату, я не зможу взяти її в наставництво в бізнесі,
я не зможу передати їй своїй компанії, щоб її брали в супровід,
тому що я бачу, що вона просідає в певних моментах.
І я не працюю, я не беру таких людей.
Мені хочеться працювати там, де я кайфую від самого процесу,
де ти можеш давати людині користь, і ти виставляєш якісь цілі,
і ти бачиш, що йде прогрес, і людина доходить до цього.
Ну, тобто виконує якийсь певний план.
Бо якщо ти приписуєш якийсь план розвитку,
і там два рази, два дні роблять, третій день пройшов,
а четвертий засіли на серіали на тиждень,
бо щось з тебе не вийшло, ну, це не пройшовує.
Для мене розвиток – це конкретні системні дії.
Є система дій, і ти їх маєш виконувати.
Незалежно від того, дощ іде, сонце світить,
Ти маєш робити усі кроки.
А якщо людина емоційно, енергетично зливається
під периферією якихось обставин,
зовнішніх якихось впливів, факторів,
вона нестабільна, нестійка,
вона не зможе виконати жодного плану.
Для мене це очевидно.
Так, згодна з вами.
Добре, дякую.
Дякую велике, дякую.
Катя Ентель, що вдалося?
На питання ще виснажує? Не виснажуємо, навпаки. Я, прошу прощення, обратила внимание, что были даже такие ситуации в жизни, когда я заболевшая, прям очень нехорошо себя чувствовала, но там просили не
переносить консультацию.
Я перенесла две консультации на нескільки днів, і вже розумією, що мені легше не стало, але провести треба. І я в моменті, включається камера, я починаю робити, проходит буквально пару минут, і я в
ресурсе.
І я якобутно як автоматом отрабатываю, я в моменті я навіть не чувствую, що болело горло, що я как-то себя відчувала по-другому.
І виключається камера, я ложу телефон, проходит какое-то время, я такая, фух, я опять как в болезненном состояниї.
Оно мене як будь-то наоборот собирает.
Це дуже прикольно, це я нескільки раз наблюдала,
що воно собирает, в тонусі таком, наоборот, тебе качає енергию.
Але зараз я обратила увагу, що в мене емоціонально-психологічне
Состояние очень
Ухудшилось
І я поняла,
Що не можу
Работать. Вот, є физическое,
Да, вот, коли ти физически себя
Плохо чувствуєш, а є вот емоціональне.
Вот емоціонально — це просто.
Я була, конечно,
Я Юрі говорила, що так смешно
Была сессія на прошлій неділю.
Я сижу, і я понимаю,
Що я слышу клиента,
А оно у мене як сквозне,
я його слухаю,
я задаю вопросы, ми йдем,
він там про фабрику свою
эту іностранну розказує, проєкти,
але я розумію, що ці 50 минут
говорив він,
я вставила якісь там пару фраз,
і я розумію,
я думаю, блин, треба було перенести
цю сесію, мені так стыдно
в моменті. А потім
в кінце він говорить,
це була лучшая сесія.
Ага, ти посмотри, у мене тут записи, я сижу такая, думаю, ну допустимо, думаю, ну может ему просто надо было прям выгодить, мне так было, я положила трубку и такая сижу, думаю, господи, що там було,
мне честно, мне казалось, что вот-вот, і він мені скажет, Кать, ну как бы, ты тут?
Включись. А я такий тупой взгляд, дайте, така, да, да, да, а он, блин, сто концов, класс, вообще, это лучше, все, я там, план поставлен, все, я такая, хорошо, вот, ну, это очень странно, знаете, так,
но я сказала себе, что я так работать больше, ну, я не буду, я пока не стабилизируюсь, я не, ну, типа, нет, ну, вот, есть какой-то сейчас у меня период, когда там,
Я сказали, там, 2-3 недели, і тоді я вже буду стабильно входити в роботу, тому що це не ок. Вот я считаю, що це прям не да, мені там повезло, вот він був в якому-то там, я не знаю, состояниї класно,
але це неправильно вступати в контакт з клієнтом, коли ти настільки емоціонально, ну, не стабильно, неуваження таке клієнтам.
Це ваше внутренне таке стане, неуваження к клієнтам, воно внутри у вас, да?
Да, да, я себя чувствовала некомфортно, я посчитала, що це неуваження к клієнту,
тому що я випадаю, я чувствовала, що я випадаю.
Опять же, я ж говорю, коли, я помню, физически мені там було плохо,
там каїта даже легка температура но меня просили говорить пожалуйста ну типа надо разобрать я
тебе долго ждала окей я собиралась я прям я настолько была в них же обменялась вух а тут
эмоционально ну как бы не взяли да вашу вашу історію можна розглядити з двох сторон тому що що
Тому що, з однієї сторони, клієнту потрібно було виговоритися, йому потрібно було виговоритися, і ви дали цей простір,
простір тому що що? Тому що воно десь скрізь вас йшло, і йшло просто таким, оп, пройшло і все.
А з другої сторони, дійсно, коли ти почуваєшся не в ресурсі, коли ти розумієш, що не зараз, не можу,
бо якщо треба включитися, якщо треба було на долі секунди включитися трошки більше, то ти розумієш, що ти там можеш випасти просто, можеш просто тупо все, я здаюсь, тому що в тебе емоційний стан так
ий.
Добре, що ви відчуваєте це, і добре, що ви даєте собі аналіз, як ви робити не будете, або як вам краще,
тому що це вам має бути також класно, кайфово, вайбово, впевненість – це клас.
Можливо, ви дали цю невербально, так, вербально подали знаки, що ви дуже впевнена, ось, і клієнт це не считав.
Дякую, що поділилися. Так, внутрішній контакт з собою, якщо ми його втрачаємо і потім на автоматі так відробляємо, ну, трошки тут треба замислитись, куди я йду далі тоді, якщо так.
Окей, клас, дякую, дякую за цей фідбек.
Розумієте, профідентичність, вона є базою, коли ми розуміємо, де, як я себе відслідковую, в мінусі, в плюсі, як я можу діяти далі, як це мене може мотивувати і до чого я прийду потім.
Тому що те, що підходить одному клієнту, іншому може не підійти, а просто послухати.
Хтось шукає одне, хтось шукає щось друге. Добре, дякую, Велика Катерина. Главне на увірі нам, Маша піше. Главне на увірі нам, все правильно. Окей, так, рухаємося далі, бо маємо ще одну практику, щоб
встигнути все і встигнути її порефлексувати.
Тому що хочу з другого блоку ще додати вам таку інформацію, де коучинг не всесильний. Ми це зрозуміли, що він має межі, де він не може працювати.
І яка межа між коучингом, терапією та наставництвом? Ось тут в Critical Moments теж ми проговорили, де Едвін Дехан описував, що найскладніші моменти для коуча виникають саме тоді, коли клієнт входить
в глибокий емоційний матеріал, коуч починає втрачати межу ролі або виникає бажання врятувати клієнта.
ось, де закінчується коучинг, що він не лікує травму, не замінює психотерапію, не передбачає, що коуч краще знає, як має жити клієнт, в якому разі, і поїхали, саме тому професійна чесність іноді про
являється в здатності сказати, як ви сказали, як і Василь до цього теж казав, що я там можу бути не в ресурсі, бажано без подробиць, або тут потрібен інший формат підтримки, як я сказала, я бачу, що ц
ей процес виходить за межі коучингу,
або зараз клієнту важливіша стабілізація, ніж рух до цілей.
Це те, що сказала Світлана Батуріна,
що клієнту важливіша, може, стабілізація наразі,
ніж рух до цілей, до цифр.
Ось, і хочу відкрити далі тему про нарцистичну прив'язку коуча
до власної ефективності.
Ось ця тема прямо така глибока.
Тут це є найглибокіша така пастка професійна, залежність коуча від результатів клієнта.
Будьте обережні, і вона часто виглядає як, якщо клієнт не змінюється, я недостатньо хороший коуч, я повинен допомогти, я маю довести свою ефективність.
Будьте, будь ласка, обережні, тому що ця динаміка часто не усвідомлюється,
але саме вона буде штовхати коуча, пришвидшувати процес,
десь тиснути, десь надавати якусь пораду, десь втрачати нейтральність,
або починати вести клієнта за собою, або підсажувати клієнта на себе.
І в психодинамічних подходах, знайомі з психодинамікою хтось,
В психодинамічних підходах це часто описується як нарцисична прив'язка до ролі помічника,
де коуч починає несвідомо використовувати результати клієнта як підтвердження власної цінності.
І тоді процес вже простає бути про клієнта, він вже про коуча.
Він вже про коуча тут, про нарцисичну частину коуча.
Ось, поїхали до Віктора Франкла.
В своїй екзистенційній концепції він наголошував, що людина не може прожити життя за іншу людину.
Так, дійсно, кожен має свою свободу вибора.
І навіть найкращий спеціаліст не може зробити ніякої зміни замість клієнта.
Ось це поняття дійсно абстрактне.
Його каже не тільки Віктор Франкл, це філософія стоїцизму також.
І також інших вчених, інших спеціалістів, довольно такі значущих.
Професійна скромність як ознака зрілості.
Про нарцисизм. Зрозуміли, так?
Що стосується нарцисичної прив'язки коуча?
Що ми не відштовхуємося від позиції клієнта, його успіхів.
Щоб не зжити успіхами клієнта.
Буває так, що клієнту наразі достатньо.
І це не говорить про те, що ми погані спеціалісти якісь.
Окей. Професійна скромність як ознака зрілості. Про що це? Це не про самознецінення, ні в якому разі, не про невпевненість або про слабкість. Це просто здатність ясно бачити межі свого впливу, межі
своєї професії, де ми є, як ми є. Це здатність бачити автономію іншої людини.
І як Роджерс також писав в своїх виданнях і в своїх замітках, що справжня допомога можлива лише тоді, коли спеціаліст не намагається контролювати внутрішній шлях клієнта.
Також, як і Франко, ми знаємо, це дійсно така думка, це база, просто база. Ми не контролюємо внутрішній шлях клієнта.
Зрілий коуч не створює культ власної експертності, не грає роль людини, яка все знає, і не робить клієнта залежним від себе.
Натомість, що він робить? Створює простір, який дуже-дуже важливий.
Підтримує усвідомлення. Визнає свободу іншої людини навіть тоді, коли її вибір не збігається з його очікуванням.
І висновки у нас такі, професійна зрілість коучу проявляється в тому, щоб витримувати межі, не допомагати кожному, а витримувати межі, не привласнювати життя клієнта, не робити себе центром процесу,
визнавати складність людських змін.
Ось це про зрілість. Залишатися чесним у професії навіть там, де немає швидких результатів. Не завжди доводити клієнта до результата, якщо він не хоче туди йти. Окей, це теж ок. Ми не всесильні.
Добре. Хочу піти далі з вами в практику. У нас запланована перерва буде через 15 хвилин, але я думаю, що ми можемо її здвинути. Що скажете на це?
Так? Добре. Після практики підемо на перерву.
Окей. Практика така. Клієнт, якого неможливо швидко змінити.
Юлічка, залишиться на цю практику 30 хвилин.
А, вибачте, 20 хвилин на кожного, 40 хвилин. Так, скоро 40 хвилин. Після 40 хвилин ми підемо.
Робота в нас в парах. Суть яка?
Практика не про ефективну сесію. Зараз ми тут не доказуємо, не показуємо якусь ефективність.
Це більше про здатність нашу залишатися в контакті в реальності, в процесі, коли клієнт може повторюватися, не рухатися швидко, сумніватися, не мати готовності до ясності чи рішення.
Ми витримуємо з вами процес, ми залишаємося в контакті, як завжди, ми не руйнуємо складність своєю якоюсь тривогою або якимись рекомендаціями.
Ми не робимо з клієнта проєкт. Не пришвидшуємо, не мотивуємо, витягуємо. Нічого цього не робимо. Добре? Клієнт, якого неможливо швидко змінити. Ось яскравий приклад. Маша з Ліною працювали.
Коли ми розуміємо, що не швидко буде цей процес, буде він швидко тільки для тієї людини, кому це потрібно, тобто для вашого клієнта.
Ось, приклад хочу додати тут, такий, я вже довго думаю про зміни в житті, але постійно повертаюся в ту саму точку і втомився, бо втомилася від цього, але ніби не можу рухатись далі.
І ось на такий приклад є такі питання. Будь ласка, заскріньте собі, вони вам, можливо, знадобляться.
Завдання можете зіграти або взяти свою життєву ситуацію, яка в вас є, про таку свою швидкість, що ви не можете.
Не можете, утрируйте, пожалуйста, свій запрос, утрируйте.
Не могу, не получается, не знаю, з чого начать, не знаю, как у мене це должно вийти.
Вот є у вас глибинний запрос, утрируйте, попробуйте увидеть його через точку катастрофизації.
У нас є таке когнитивне викривлення, коли ми катастрофізуємо.
Зараз я прошу вас, як клієнта, коли в ролі клієнта ви будете, в ролі коучі,
стрифізуйте свою ситуацію для того, щоб можливо знайти
більш ефективну відповідь на ваше питання.
Окей?
Окей.
Бачу слухачів.
Добре.
Окей, все, ми готові.
Якщо питань нема, ми готові.
Зали теж готові і на 40 хвилин практика, так, дивлюсь, так, відкриваю зали.
Дякую.
Боже, знову англійський дощ. Щойно було сонечко.
Катарина, а ви тут?
Супер.
Да, Катарина вже пішла в зал.
У вас дождь, а в нас груза прям так гремить.
Тут погода, просто я уже не знаю, у меня за окном за сутра сменилось, наверное, все 4 сезона, только снег еще не пішел.
Ні, у нас прям літо-літо, знаєте, так, жара і от вечором гриза така почалась.
Тільки-тільки ще сніг не пішов, єй-богу, не знаю, що це буде далі, але літо обіцяють на півдні Англії аномально.
Яке аномально, не знаю, був град, недавно, пару днів назад був град, взагалі, взагалі я в шокі була.
Такий крупний, побил цветочки.
Ой-ой-ой. Ну, значить буде жара, напевно, прям…
Будем надіяться.
Буде прям хорошо.
Ого, я слышу! Нічого себе!
Да-да, тут прям гремить. Я переживаю, щоб у мене інтернет не виглядається.
А це де? Це в Україні, де?
Да, Ужгород.
Да, у нас прям хорошо.
Окей, ладно.
Іду я в кімнату послухати.
Дякую, дякую велике.
Дякую вам.
А, вибачте, Юлія, доки не пішла.
Так, кажіть.
А де, ви сказали, запис у нас іде на Ютуб?
А де ми на Ютубі?
Скиньте мені посилання, будь ласка, в ТГ.
Так, стидаю.
Дякую, бо я не бачила, де там у нас є ютубчик.
Це просто трансляція на ютубі, і тоді не займається пам'ять на жорсткому диску.
А, тобто там ніхто не бачить, там бачать тільки студенти наші.
Так, там закрите посилання.
Ага, ось як. І тут пам'ять.
Ага, все, зрозуміло, дякую.
Дякую велико.
Тересом скину.
Дякую.
Будь ласка.
Дякую за перегляд!
Прийшло. Пройдясь по всім кімнаткам, реально почула, що навіть не треба було катастрофізувати.
Добре, Ірина Купчик, дякую, що доєдналися. Дуже рада вас бачити.
В нас на черзі трошки ми рухали перерву, тому на 10 хвилинчик йдемо на перерву, на Кавузьку.
і повертаємося з вже відгуками, що в нас вдалося в цієї практиці.
Добре?
Добре.
Дякую за перегляд!
Так, повертаємось.
Окей, ну що ж, продовжуємо.
Юля Кравчук, Юрій Доган, тож поділіться, що у вас там вдалося вирішити на практиці.
Ми двоєчніки, ми обговорили, як Аишка може нам допомогти в нашій роботі.
Делились тим, що у кого, що відбувається в цьому направлі.
Ну і як би все.
Окей, хорошо.
Хорошо. То есть профорієнтація та профнапрямок вже вирішений?
У мене поки, да.
Супер. Це класно. І це класно. Це теж результат і дуже гарний результат. Добре. Добре, дякую.
Дякую. Добре. Лера, що вдалося в вас за Настією?
Ну, нам було комфортно. Разговаривали на такій дуже...
В дуже глубинній чистоте, і вопросы змогли углубитися ще глибше.
Удалось что-то увидеть, які-то ответи относительно того, о чому ви разговаривали?
Да, удалось увидеть ответи на такі неявні вопросы, і, ну, завжди інтересніше, коли не просто по поверхності, а именно прям вот глубинно-глубинно-глубинно, да, ісследовання йдет.
Угу, є об кого подумати.
Да, да, все верно, іменно об цьому я і говорю.
Угу, отлично, супер.
Окей, зараз перефеликсуємо ще більш детальніше.
Я хочу повернутися до наших слайдів і завершити сьогоднішній день третім блоком, який в нас є.
Тож, бачу, хтось доєднався, хтось ні.
Вмикайте камеру, якщо ви є.
Що стосовно практики, клієнт, якого неможливо змінити, це більше про запит, на який ви орієнтуєтесь, результат, з якого ви хочете зрозуміти або отримати для себе,
щоб далі рухатись в своєму професійному напрямку.
Я бачила, що більшість з вас, як ментор-коучі вже,
як коучі, як ментор-коучі, із класичної позиції,
і не тільки, вже дійсно потужні, такі сильні спеціалісти.
Тому трошки більше впевненості, віри в себе, і все вдасться.
Це 100%. Трошки більше впевненості.
Все у нас вдасться. Я вас завіряю, більше практики.
Окей, що ж, наостанок у нас найсмачнюче.
Як у нас, деякі з нас кажуть, смакота, смачно, смачно.
І я теж цим словом надихнулася, теж кажу вже смачнюче, смачно.
Філософія коуча, третій блок.
Філософія, професійна філософія коуча.
Що в нас тут є? Ключова ідея яка?
Цей фінальний блок першого дня буде присвячений не технікам, не моделям,
а буде присвячений на те, на що я опираюсь як коуч.
Тому що я часто сьогодні почула про внутрішній контакт з собою, про те, як я себе відчуваю.
І якщо є з цим якийсь такий запит глибинний, то третій блок якраз про вас.
На певному етапі професійного розвитку коуч більше не може спиратися лише на інструменти, на сертифікацію, на дипломи, на структури сесії або правильне питання.
Тому що реальна практика, вона неминуче буде стикати з невизначеністю, зі складністю, з людською болю про те, що ми казали, з неоднозначністю і відсутністю ідеальних рішень.
І це ок. Саме в цей момент у нас проформується професійна філософія коуча, тобто, виходячи з практики.
І професійна філософія – це внутрішня система поглядів, через які ми, як спеціалісти, бачимо людину, розуміємо зміни, сприймаємо її свободу, розуміємо її свободу, ставимося до відповідальності і буду
ємо власну практику.
Це є відповіді на питання, в що я вірю як коуч, що для мене значить зрілість, чи може людина змінитися, що таке свобода клієнта, де межа мого впливу, чи можна врятувати іншу людину.
Ось це всі відповіді є тут. Тобто і сприймати, і розуміти людину, і поважати її, і погляд, і релігію, і ідеї, і напрямок, в якому вона рухається, і темп, в якому вона також рухається.
Я взяла тут також Віктора Франкла ще раз про екзистенційний, боже, заговорюсь вже сьогодні, екзистенційний вимір коучингу.
Він писав, що одна з головних потреб людини – це пошук сенсу.
І у нього є книга «Чоловік в поисках смисла».
Якщо я не помиляюсь, я вже цю книгу або вам казала, або клієнтам.
але дуже класна книга, почитайте її.
«Человек в поїзках смисла» Віктор Франкл.
Але сенс не може бути нав'язаний ззовні, звісно, його неможливо дати клієнту.
Людина має зустрітися з ним сама через біль, через страждання, можливо,
можливо, через якісь етапи, знаєте, бар'єри, де людину хвилює просто на цих хвилях,
просто цунамі якесь, і тоді вона цей сенс почує і впізнає.
Ялом також наголошував, що багато людських трудніщів пов'язані не лише з цілями та ефективностями, а також з самотністю, свободою, страхом невизначеності, смертністю та пошуком справжнього контакту з
собою.
Ось ця невизначеність, якщо ви побачили сьогодні, вона звучить дуже-дуже часто.
Тому що невизначеність, неопредільність, це пугає, це те, що нас лякає, тому що вона дає тривогу, а тривога, звісно, дає сув і сумніви, сув в власних цінностях, вони суваються і лякають нас, збивають
з толку, збивають з напрямку і ми вже починаємо сумніватися, куди ми йдемо і що ми робимо, і дійсно це так або не дійсно.
І вже починає клієнт десь сумніватися в тому, чи взагалі це вірний або не вірний напрямок, помилковий або ні і так далі.
Саме тому зріла, доросла, професійна особа, коуч не зводить роботу лише до досягнення результатів.
Якщо пам'ятаєте, говорили про нарцесичну частину себе. Тобто коуч не зводить роботу до досягнених результатів, до продуктивності або правильного мислення.
Коуч, ментор-коуч, екзекютів-коуч, він бачить за запитом «живу людину», в першу чергу.
Да, це може бути дійсно як слова, я розумію, вони такі абстрактні і так далі, і так далі.
Але в процесі практики це більше буде для вас розумітися, глибоко буде розумітися, як це можна трактувати.
Ось, далі поїхали. Стоїцизм. Дуже поважаю стоїцизм як внутрішня професійна опора.
Ми також у цьому модулі інтегрували вже елементи стоїчної філософії, продовжуємо їх інтегрувати.
І не тільки в цьому модулі, це вже набагато кроків далі, далі, далі, це вже і в минулому було, і далі буде про філософію як професійного порукоюча.
Стоїки, вони не вчили емоційної холодності, навпаки, стоїцизм досліджували, але, але, битує таке поняття, що стоїцизм дуже холодний.
Це зовсім не так. Досліджували вони що? Як залишатися внутрішньостійкими у складності життя, особливо зараз, коли ми розкидані, коли ми не на своєму місці, коли ми дійсно трошки такі хиткі, скажімо
так, хиткі на даному етапі, буває таке.
Хтось більш, хтось менш, але це є.
Як не втрачати себе в хаосі зовнішніх обставин та як зберігати ясність мислення?
Тому що дійсно хаос зовнішніх обставин дає нам таку багатську просто, не знаю, віз сумнівів, знову ж таки, де я, що я роблю і куди я іду, і навіщо мені це треба і так далі.
Тобто стоїцизм рекомендую вивчати далі, досліджувати і брати її для себе, цю філософію, як професійну опору для себе.
Епіктєд, обожнюю, наголошує, людина не може контролювати все, що відбувається навколо, але можна працювати за своїм ставленням і вибором.
Не тільки епіктід, багато дійсно, багатька купа навчених, просто гора така, яка також говорить звідусюди, що людина не може контролювати все, що відбувається навколо, але може працювати за своїм став
ленням і вибором.
І також Аронбек також казав, що не обставини на нас впливають, а то, як ми мислим над цим, як ми ставимося, наше мислення, як працює.
І для коуча це означає, що я не контролюю життя клієнта, звісно, я не можу прожити його шлях замість нього.
Контролюйте всі свої слова, коли ви говорите до клієнта,
як ви це говорите, як це до нього доноситься, як він це відчуває.
Рухи, помічайте рухи також, як клієнт рухається на ваші слова,
бо рухи сразу, навіть якщо словами через рот клієнт не скаже,
але рухи вони все видають.
Ось, для коуча ще, що означає, не можна контролювати все, не можна гарантувати результат, але може залишитися присутнім, ясним і чесним у процесі.
Професійна ідентичність ментор-коуча на завершальному етапі навчання важливо для нас, для всіх вас, не лише вміти працювати, а й розуміти, ким ви є в цієї професії.
Ким ви є? Ментор-коуч – це не просто людина з інструментами, а спеціаліст, який вже здатний витримувати будь-яку складність, бачити межі професії своєї, звісно, не руйнує автономію клієнта, не будує
власню цінність через порятунок інших, знову про нарцисизм кажу, і створює простір для усвідомлення, а не залежності.
І інтеграційний висновок цього блоку, це професійна філософія коуча, вона формується не тільки через техніки. Технік є багато, багатсько, просто на ютубчику можна знайти, в соціальних мережах багато
технік, з якими можна працювати.
Важливо ось ці компетенції, які ми з вами повторюємо, всі компетенції, які ми з вами вивчали. Ось ця присутність, ось це вміння слухати, ось це створення простору, ось це усвідомлення і повага до
простору клієнта.
Ось це важливе. Любу техніку, як фідбек був з попередньої практики, з першої Настя сказала, що я розумію, що я можу давати, брати різні інструменти.
Інструмент – це ви самі, ви і є інструмент. Ваші навички, які ви тут вивчаєте, ось це ваш інструмент.
Ви самі є інструмент для другої людини. Філософія коуча формується через чесний контакт із реальністю в професії, усвідомлення меж, зустріч з власною вразливостю, як також хтось написав плакательна к
імната, туди, якщо вразливість є, туди будь ласка, створюйте осередки,
Як Маша Храб також сказала, я створила ком'юніці, там можна, там можна, так, можна, так, можна, так.
Надихаюсь, є вразлива, там десь сама собі щось сказала, десь не так, десь щось себе підманула, підвела, пішла.
І там знайшла всі відповіді для себе.
Професійна філософія коуча формується також за поступовим формуванням внутрішньої опори.
Саме це є перехід від людини, яка проводить сесії, до зрілого ментор-коуча.
Тому що людина, яка до вас приходить, людина, вона в першу чергу шукає опору в вас.
Якщо людина безопорна, спеціаліст безопорний клієнт це считує.
Він считує, він відчуває.
Відчуває безопорного клієнта.
І неважливо, в якій ви ситуації, повірте.
Чи ви розлучена, чи ви без грошей, чи ви так, чи ви сяк.
Людина може бути в любому стані, але якщо вона є та опора внутрі вас,
ви знаєте вже заздалегідь, як ви вийдете з цього моменту, з цієї кризи.
Як також така дуже відома психотерапевтка, вона тут в Великобританії,
Я не можу згадати, Наомі її звуть, не Кембл, ні, афроамериканка.
Вона сказала, все, що є, який стрес в нас є, все, що в нас коїться в житті, якщо тільки це не смерть, це все початок нового.
Все є початок нового, все. Ні більш, не менш.
І тому, якщо є ця внутрішня опора,
неважливо, в якому ви,
де ви, як ви, якщо ви відчуваєте себе.
Я ок, я знаю, як з цього це.
Це зараз просто час такий.
І бувають такі часи, де може бути щось не так.
Може бути, да, може бути.
Дайте собі час відпочити.
Підійте там в плакательну кімнату, поплачтеся.
В ком'юніці організуйте, хто ще хоче поплакати.
ось або десь
якісь моменти такі
соціалізуйтеся трошки більше
виходьте і все
буде ок
я кажу, якщо це тільки на смерть
не дай Боже, а все інше
це початок нового
старе закінчиться, нове починається
так?
так
і не кажіть, що не так, не може бути не так
ось, що
сьогодні ми завершили важливий етап
На сьогодні і в нас залишився один день
Ми вийшли за межі технік, інструментів, правильних сесій
Але я хочу сказати, що ми вийшли за ці межі вже давно
Не тільки сьогодні
Ми почали досліджувати реальність професії
І ми її почали не тільки сьогодні досліджувати, а вже два модулі назад
Ми досліджували емоційну ціну допомагаючої ролі
Межі коучингу, власну професійну філософію
здатні залишатися живою людиною всередині своєї професії.
І ми знаємо, що насправді відбувається з коучем після завершення навчання та виходу у практику.
Да, розгубленість є. Ну, нічого, буває, так, буває, це ок.
Ми розуміємо, як допомагаючі професії впливають на особистість коуча.
Впливають, так.
Що таке emotional load? Що таке invisible emotional labor?
це накопичення чужих історій, де треба вигрузитися.
Як коуч поступово може втрачати контакт з собою
і залишаєтесь тільки функціонуючим фахівцем?
Це також все тут важливе, все, що ми тут навчаємось, все це важливе.
Ми знаємо, чому професійна зрілість включає визнання меж коучингу.
Так, бо ми знаємо, де є межа коучингу.
Про психологію сьогодні я дуже сподіваюся, що це була для вас не новинка.
Це треба розуміти дуже, прямо регламент такий є, є не тільки етика, це регламент, це протоколи, розумієте?
Є поняття, коли ми регулюємося, коригуємося етикою, але етика що? Етика, ок, добре, але є регламенти, є протоколи, ось, за протоколами працюється.
Ми розуміємо, що формується власне професійна філософія коуча.
Як вона формується? Через упору, через контакт з собою.
Так вона і формується, через свою практику.
І на що насправжді спирається зрілий ментор-коуч у довгостроковій практиці?
Ось, так?
Ми спираємося в цілому на себе.
На себе любих ми спираємося.
Це ціна є коучинга, да ми можемо йти різними шляхами, хтось іде у провокативну психологію, хтось у когнітивну психологію, хтось у коучинг і так далі.
Ми розуміємо завжди, що є ціна і рано чи пізно нам потребується оцей простір, це як ємність, якась ємність, яка може визначатися кількістю людей,
якусь кількість людей, де ми можемо себе підтримати. Один в полі не воїн. Не все можна купити за гроші.
Один в полі трактор. Я не машина, я лідокол нахуй. Знаєте цей прикол?
ти не машина щоб всі стріляться і там я лідокол нахуй і за вами буду сумувати прям найбільше
а залишайтесь на другий потік на третій ідіть на третій будьте навчати якщо мені оплатити
він научить Плахому не пускайте його на три
це не будь ласка не до мене не добре тож що зрозуміло з сьогоднішньої лекції що є зрозуміло
ми повторюємо багато багатсько просто повторюємо по не знаю вже який circle в нас іде але є
вимикайте мікрофон Юрій настроєння бути лісічкою нести людям улыбку бешенство і смерть дякуємо
я даже не знаю якщо б ми були всі отут в школі знаєте і в одному класі ну просто вчитель
щоб зійшов з розуму тільки один Юрій і от весь клас 20 людей не знаю Ви б зірвали всі уроки Навірно
я був перший в своєму селі в школі в класці це був до кого в класна криничка йшла додому
типу не просто викликала батьків в школу йшла зі мною додому до батьків
щоб ви дійшли додому бо ви губилися по дорозі так ні бо я зробив дуже погані речі бігав за ласичкою
добре дякую що взяли з цього модулю Юрій я позитивний настрій хороші емоції
що ще добре давайте так все ще багато посмішок
якщо ви хочете почути щось про користь я не скажу я не дуже був дитячний в діалог
от закрив пару задач посміявся от пробував включатися в діалог але для мене це було щось
ніби якісь підготовчі курси на 10 модуль, якщо чесно, мене воно вибивало.
Мені здалося, що тут вже кожен мав знайти свою внутрішню опору, і зовнішню опору, і колективну опору, і групову опору, і міні-групову опору, і опорну опору.
Коротше, всі опори, які мали б бути, вже мали б бути. А тих, які не мали б бути, вже мали б відсіятися.
і кожен мав би зловити світ зен і найти своє щастя все досить філософії ми нехороший
настрій просто світ все класно це класно все класно ми ловимо дзен разом з вами все
класно дякую велик дякую Юрі з нами залишайтеся з нами і на завтра добре Амінь Настя
Калибровка, а то Юрий все вспомнил, і я тут, знаєте, отрефлексировала, і свій комбайн вспомнила, і трактор, і комбайн, да, вот, і, как это, що бы делали, вот у мене щас ребенок учиться, вот їх собр
али всіх в один клас, ви поняли?
І вони там друг друга аж гай шуме, щоб вони не мешали іншим класам, їх собрали в один клас.
А що сьогодні забирали? Классний був модуль, класне було заняття,
тому що така необхідна в кінці, на фінішній навсегда. Нужна така ще раз калибровка.
Откалиброватися, де ти, що ти, як ти, і бачити на ті же самі питання, але вже пройдя такий путь.
путь, тому для мене це було
дуже важливо, знайти
внутренній уже
і спокійного
состояния, да, і
плохой, хороший коуч,
таке діло відносительно, і,
получается, прийняв
рішення ми.
Какой ми коуч?
Сьогодні, плохой или хороший?
Однозначно, ніхто вам не скаже,
ніхто вам не скаже, які
вітом...
Да, то есть в конце сессії оценить свою собственную роботу на рефлексії можеш тільки ти, а остальные, получается, ну, как бы даже клиент може теж сказати своє мнение.
Поэтому мені ця калибровка сьогодні дала ще раз, да, з іншої позиції посмотреть на себе, пройдя цей путь.
Благодарю.
І я благодарю вас. Спасибо огромное, що були.
Що помітили і що собі забрали цю цінність?
Дякую. Аліна.
Значить, сьогоднішнє наше заняття, воно дало мені чітке розуміння мого зросту.
Моїї точки А на початку навчання і точки Б чітко, структурно.
Ще моменти, на які мені потрібно звернути увагу, я їх, ну, ще раз, да, все одно, ти знаєш, але якось воно старається під тиском різних життєвих навіть обставин, да,
і час від часу потрібно все одно повертатися в той список ось цих характеристик, де ти, да, а де ти, ні, і рефлексувати, да,
Де ще? Де ти просів?
Тому що в будь-якому випадку людина не може просто йти вгору, вгору, вгору, вгору.
Все одно ми десь пішли вгору, трошки просіли.
Десь пішли вгору, трошки просіли.
Типу сама крива вона вгору йде, але тим не менше.
І дуже цінно саме для тих, хто хоче практикувати і бути ефективним спеціалістом, повертатися в цю рефлексію.
Так що дякую, Лана, що дали можливість.
Дякую, Великий. Так, повертатися... Дякую, Аліно.
Повертатися в рефлексію – це обов'язково.
Обов'язково.
Де є терапія, де немає терапії, де є супервізія або немає супервізії –
в рефлексію – це завжди.
Вона працює. Дякую. Добре.
Тетяна Артемова.
Так, я дуже дякую за зустріч сьогодні.
Для мене це таке ще одне нагадування про те,
що вже всіх достатньо знань достатньо є своя опора треба рухатися вперед до своїх великих
цілей і насправді знань вже достатньо вже вже все заглибилось максимально over працювати
так знань вже over дякую дуже дякую немає виникати вже що недо немає вже немає відмазок все
дякую нема куди стрибати є є завжди куди стрибати якщо ми хочемо да але на даному етапі вже для
практики це все предостатньо клас вже клієнти недостатні так шукаємо вже важких ось коли знаєте
коли ви будете шукати клієнтів які по вашу будь ласка давай мені якого психоза якогось там ще щось
ще щось щось щось давай мені амбіції якісь великих високих і що ось Юро візьміть
можна график списувати повністю якщо один Юра буде у него у него клієнт
хто не здох, хто лох, у нього там амбіцій хватить на кожного.
Дай одразу, що ти неєш.
Ви тут не починаєте, тут багато хто був в мене на сесі.
Тому і говоримо, Юр, говоримо тільки те, що прожито.
Нічого, ніякої етепрітації, ні, ні, ні.
Ну все, ви не здохли, ви не лохи, знаєте.
Мені сподіваються Андрій Зардоном.
Скажіть мені, я лох чи ви лох?
Хм, я не лох, а ви, може, і лох.
Так, ми лохи чи не лохи?
Под запис. Все йде под запис.
Але ви все-таки якісь серйозні.
Насправді ми улыбаємось.
Це правильно.
У нас все прекрасно.
У вас серйозна професія.
Це я тут позалю.
Нет, Юра, ми просто психіатрию все проходимо.
Там неизгладиме впечатление просто.
Уже примерилася, що є.
У меня не прошла психіатрию.
Кстати, она дуже багато потратила мене.
Мені ж інтересно, як би у вас прошла, як ви сказали.
Ну, а такий анамнез мені выдало, що мені саму стало інтересно посмотрить.
Я поняла, що ми, короче, недообследовані, походу.
Ну, лично я.
Де ви проходили психіатрию? Я прошу про бачення.
В МСММ, в любимому. Доктор Ісанко подала інформацію. Тесты проходить, взагалі, я дуже впечатлений, а мені нелезя так.
Протестили, да? Прекрасно, прекрасно. Не в моїй компетенції говорить о психіатриї, але я думаю, вам полезно.
Ви не вирішуєте себе, що ваша компетенція, що не ваша. Ваші компетенції висловлювати свою думку.
Ні, ви може висловлювати свою думку стосовно коучингу.
Ні, стосовно всього, чого хочете. Кожен день має право на думку.
Звісно, тому і кажуть, що корисно. Буде дуже корисно. Дякую.
Чується нотка професійності.
Для того, щоб услышати на інші теми Лану, її потрібно славити буде в сентябрі в Одесі.
Катя тими займеться.
Це як визов, так.
Там і поговоримо.
Добре, що ж, в нас сьогодні коучинг.
Ми завершуємо цей перший день.
На темі коучингу, на тему ментор-коучу.
Я дуже-дуже рада, що ви є сьогодні тут, в цьому складі.
Не буду поки що говорити, що я буду за вами сумувати.
В нас є ще в МСММ другий потік, але ми з вами на зв'язку.
І в нас ще завтра великий день.
Там вже буде друга рефлексія.
Скажи, що там підготувати, щоб я підготував якось цікаво.
Книгу по МКБ підготуйте.
Що підготувати?
Книгу по МКБ.
Що таке МКБ?
Международна класифікація болезнів. Вам разве не сказали?
Международна? Що?
Класифікація болезнів. Одиннадцятій желатень.
Це психіатрия, Юра, який пройшов іскусний інтелект. Забудь.
Мене аж на цьому інтернет підвіс.
Так, говорили про 10 і 11.
Там токенів не вистачає, Юр, не ниряй.
Я за першу ділю на десятку токенів потратив.
Я охеряв, коли мені когось це показав.
Угу, добре.
То там, де немає нових хвороб, називається.
Немає.
Я просто пишу в різні своїх состояниях, я треба більше.
Гомосексуальність там дозволена, там все норм.
Так, так, все окей.
Ми в Європі.
Ми в психіатрію проходимо, добре.
Прекрасно, прекрасно. Я її проходжу тут.
В нас це називається ICD, DSM-5, ICD-11.
Тут дві книги в Великобританії.
Дуже корисно, нічого немає спільного тут, прямого спільного скоучингу,
але типи особистості бажано розуміти, трошки для себе розширювати, знати.
Я знаю, що це важко, але якщо цікаво, беріть, це знадобиться.
для розширення знадобиться дійсно знадобиться тому я дуже рада що Світлана Ісаєнко є з вами
також а можливо я також зайду на лекцію у вас завтра буде лекція у нас лекції в записі у нас в
записі да можете попросити що вам доступно в воскресенье буде недію щось має бути
Ну не спеціаленка що у нас психіатрія випроси відповідно там който від нее бікбос її заміститель
має бути в 16-20 по Києву психіатрия QNA Ну прекрасно прекрасно прекрасно беріть все беріть
все бо це класні інструменти вони працюють беріть все ось а не знаю Настя кому вам ти сказав
Ви там комусь щось сказали.
Вас мащають, беріть усе, знаєте, а як це нести все.
А нести, так.
Тягти його вже важко.
Я вже на крийць мови перейшла, бо почуття мої.
Просто улітило з пестища мій кудись.
Я вже не можу, не вивозю.
Ну, психіатрія реально складна, дуже складна.
Особливо в початку, там термінологія,
Дальше вже, коли там про шизофрінію биполярною,
коли вже по діагнозу, вже хоч німножко легче.
А вначале таке кількість просто терминів.
Я не знаю, як це можна запомнить.
Які запомітації якісь?
Хто термин?
Ну, мені більше там в болезнях запоміналось вже.
По діагнозам?
По діагнозам, да.
Манія, гипоманія.
Це два типи биполярно-аффективного расстройства, бар.
Есть один тип, есть второй тип.
Одних держат у нас в психіатричній лечебніці,
а другие у нас прекрасно ходять по вулиці.
А ми чоловік в воєнному госпіталі кажуть, що на кожній курілці.
Такі історії, як вони голими руками вертоліти залишилися.
Не ці люди, я взагалом, те, що в психіатрії у нас.
Так що всі ці люди між нами.
Я просто не знаю, але в Україні зараз вже немає такого обов'язкового лікування.
Якщо раніше було принудово, то зараз немає.
І якщо приходять пацієнти, я просто в 15-й, ну, була не понаслышки.
і дуже, ну, я імпатична, мені дуже тяжело, психіатрия дається, я не можу, я дуже імпатична к цим людям,
вот, це моя душі одна какая-то історія.
Ти вже екзамени посмотрела відео у нас?
Я смотрела, я до середини дошла і все, я не можу далі йти, ну, правда,
потому що я даже знаю цей кабінет, я там була, я ж не понаслышки, і мені тачки просили носити,
Ну, це тяжело, чесно, мені вічно це тяжело, і тому в психіатрії йде бунт, протест.
Розумію вас, я працювала в психіатричній клініці у нас в Одесі,
іще в старій такій, в Савдеповському, пострадяйському, де нема опалення, нема нічого.
Ось таке у нас відео екзамінаціонне. Примерно з такої больниці.
Не з такої, а з 15-го. Цей кабінет іменно в 15-й больниці в нашій.
І Саїнка, в принципі, і робота.
З такої же старої. З такої же, Настя, з такої же старої.
Скоріше всього, без отопління. Ось так все печальненько.
Так, так, так. Це реалі. Це реалі. Це дійсно реалі.
Ось, і кожного разу до тебе приходять, приводять, привозять, притягують, приволокюють людину в дуже цікавому стані.
Тому дійсно книги, які є у доктора Ісайенко, вони не народилися з GPT-чату, не народилися, вони не народилися.
я це прекрасно розумію як працівник психіатричної клініки як був бивший працівник
психіатричної клініки я розумію де це народжиться і дійсно ці люди є і да не всі великовні на жаль
Я не можу там відпочити емпатію, нікак.
Добре, всіх обіймаю, час наш сьогодні сплив вже зустрінемось в Одесі, може десь в іншій країні, десь з вами зустрінемось обов'язково, на сьогодні це все.
Завтра будуть інші теми ось тому всіх обійняла гарного всім залишку дня або
до вечора на зв'язку і до завтра до завтра може ще 9 хвилин порозганяємо якийсь Comedy Club
де порозганяємо Comedy Club тут прямо тут в нас вже час вийшло
Юра ти не знаєш розкладу Юра ти не в курсі розкладу Вона може хоче вже поїсти
розклад 20-30 нас 21-20 закінчується сьогодні в мене теж 30 стоїть в календарі в мене теж 20
Я не буду вас заставляти побачимося завтра побачимося завтра на зв'язку на зв'язку спасибо большое